the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
the queens of the Chess World are
shining like diamonds at the Cairns Cup
in Saint Louis
following the rest day players put on
their hard hats and quickly went to work
searching for any advantage they could
find Alexandra castenick went straight
for the heart fiercely dismantling Irena
crush with the white pieces to remain in
the hunt for the crown Anna satonski won
a gem of the game continuing her
incredible performance in extending her
lead will a rival poison her chances for
a fairy tale ending or will her moves
over the board continue to be the
fairest of them all day seven of
thrilling chess coming up next
[Music]
thank you
hello everyone welcome back to round
seven of the Karen's cup we are here in
the Central West End in a beautiful
location I have the feeling the games of
today's round are gonna be just as
beautiful let's go to the studio and get
the action started
welcome to Saint Louis the home of Chess
in America and the third edition of the
Karens cup one of the richest women's
tournaments in chess we come to you live
from the Saint Louis chess club
thank you
good morning and welcome everyone thank
you for joining us I'm International
and I'm here with my brilliant co-host
yes everyone I see it's so much fun
calling me action with you and Almer I
tell you I've just been enjoying it all
so thank you very much oh thank you too
absolutely hello everyone and welcome to
the Anna zatonski show it sure feels
that way as Anna is putting together an
absolutely Sterling performance will she
turn it into a grand master Norm well to
borrow an expression only time will tell
Nasi do the honors please and tell us
about the standings after six rounds of
play Let's Take a look in the clear
first is Aina satonski lead in the
tournament with four and a half points
in the clear second following closely
Elizabeth pets with three and a half
points and you see some of the players
have played five games some of the
players have played six games and that
is because humpy canero our defending
Champion dropped out so some players are
gonna have to buy thank you that's right
and in Sharing Third Place Alexander
question
for example right here with players
who've only played five games and our
format
we have a nine player round robin where
no draws are allowed no draw offers are
allowed right it feels like no draws
have been unlocked and the time control
is 90 minutes for first 40 moves 30
minutes rest of the game and 30 second
increment from move one and our
remaining schedule the players will play
a total of nine rounds and today begins
round seven however on June 13th we may
have playoffs exactly a special day in
case there's a tie for first
and we're very happy to have in studio
Almera uh who's going to tell us about
these amazing number of the decisive
games bonjour Almera hello yes sir hello
uh well hey we had so many decisive
games in this round and even though we
had a few draws there have been fighting
rows as you've Nazi has told you that
draws are not allowed in this tournament
draw author so let's have a look how
does it break down round by round so it
started with the bank 75 percent of the
size of games then even a better score
100 percent I don't know how can we have
something more then the ladies slow down
a little bit uh 50 and around three the
same and around four and then the
fatigue started to We The Players
started to fill the fatigue so 25 and
around five and then in the round six
once again we had an astonishing number
or 75 percent of the size of games which
brings it to the overall number of 60 63
percent of
decisive games which for classical chess
is an amazing number sometimes the
organizer would be happy if there is
like 33 percent up to 40 percent of the
size of games so uh the number speaks
for themselves uh Anna zetonsky who's
leading the tournament so far let's have
a look at her score she won all three
games with the black pieces and she
scored four and a half points out of six
in this tournament uh she Drew all her
games with white pieces and today she
actually has a buy I wanted to tell you
that Anna is writing her own history
because she might become the first
American player to win this event and
also she is on the Voyager scoring her
first Grand Master norm and on the verge
of winning the strongest Tournament of
her life how important it is for her
today she gets a buy then let's
have a look at her road ahead so bye in
today's round round seven and around
eight she will face jeansai abdomalik
which she doesn't do so great in this
tournament so Anna has a real chance of
winning this game and in the round nine
we will have an absolute Clash of
American heavyweights Anna will face
Irina Crush
your thoughts about the last round yes
yeah well I was going to say what an
irony that these two legendary uh
players of women's chess in the United
States should clash in the last round
that's that's something to look forward
very exciting match but uh laid the
table for our audience Nasi and tell
them what they can expect in today's
round seven appearance let's take a look
we have jeansai Abdul Malik playing
gunai mamatara The Clash of the
youngsters I would say Irina crash
playing harika Drano Valley
nanotechnitza against Alexandra kosnuke
and Bella hota shrille playing Elizabeth
pets a very important game there on
table four and by round for Anna zatoski
we've seen the clash of the decisive
games what are they all fighting for
they're fighting for a lot of money
there is total of hundred and eighty
thousand dollars in prizes the first
place winner is going to win forty five
thousand dollars second place thirty
five thousand third twenty five thousand
prizes all the way down to the tenth of
final place of six thousand dollars I
don't want to jinx
on a but boy what how meaningful would
that be to get the Grand Master Norm we
she's going to She's Gotta Buy today but
then she's going to need to score two
draws or basically 50 in our two
remaining games as we see Bella talk
about a player who doesn't like to draw
she started with two losses two losses
and then three wins in a row right can
she make she can she keep her streak
alive Almera what are you expecting for
that very big game between Elizabeth and
Bella
while both players have been playing
very uncomforting chess so I think that
this is going to be a real fight and
Bella is playing with the white pieces
so
um she's she does not play solidly in
the opening actually she takes chances
so it might be also a very good chance
for Elizabeth to seize the initiative
and catch Anna in the lead
[Music]
and we saw a picture there of Alexandra
as again she adjusts the pieces I do the
same I do the the the pieces first then
the pawns and I put my Knights forward
just as Alexander the best so she's very
well trained
and talk about the heavyweights Clash
yes you have them in front of you Nana
with white pieces against the former
world champion Alexandra christianook
this is going to be tough I'm sure
they've played each other many times
yeah
amazing what they had to head is yeah
and the two youngest players in the
tournament exactly
I wonder how many times they've played
with each other because again they're
just so young they couldn't have that
much experience
right
yeah and also I think that you forget
that they started so young that they've
probably played a lot of games in the
world youth chess championships that's a
good point when we were talking I
remember about Sergey karakin and Magnus
Carlsen I think their first game they
played when they were 10. that was their
first encounter and maybe also was for
the gold medals too because they were so
successful as young players harika at
the board
going off the score sheet
um good time to once again remind our
viewers we love it when you join the
conversation we had some wonderful
questions queries and uh from the social
media and Sabina is the one handling the
questions yes you can join the
conversation on Twitter using hashtag
Karen's cup and on every other social
media platform you can reach us at the
St Louis chess club channels
and I love those questions so keep them
coming there you see Arena everybody is
getting there
yeah a later rifle but everybody gets
wanted so sometimes there is a little
line up there as we hear Judith in the
background the chief Arbiter I think
today we have a special guest ringing
the bell oh
do you know who it is Alexander
okay
but we're gonna see him on the screen
shortly
oh actually that's his daughter oh
I was about to say is the Bell bigger
well done Alex
very cute
first moves on the board
and
which game which one
tournament leader has a bite today we
have to pick the key match absolutely
well for me it's got to be the Bella
versus Elizabeth because if you look at
the point totals between them they're
they're sporting the most points so the
fight for second and potentially first
you mentioned that if Elizabeth could
win wow uh Anna has a buy today and
can't score obviously when you have the
buy Elizabeth could go to four and a
half and she's uh playing this uh this
uh A6 H6 uh interesting just two days
ago opponent played Knight C3 and she
responded with age six right now Bella
plays Knight F3 and Elizabeth goes Asics
exactly and again this is uh uh kind of
like a modern style and I want to say
that Magnus Carlson kind of responsible
I think in many ways for popularizing a
move that well the classical players
would suggest is not that good but okay
D takes C4 and the potential of B7 B5
exists so uh you might say black is
threatening to capture a pawn and to
keep it I think the most common response
is just taken on
the avoid D takes C4 comes it takes D5
e takes D5 Knight C3 Knight F6 Bishop G5
lots and lots of games have been going
in this fashion yes we'll see what
Bella's choice is you think A7 A6 is a
surprise
if Elizabeth hasn't played it before
then I'm sure Bella was not expecting it
slight slight surprise
um just uh again I'm thinking if the
threat is to take and if I don't want to
play E3 to stop the threat Queen C2
you know getting ready to transpose it
into a Catalan uh might be uh an
interesting choice and let's see as we
go around in the youngsters game we have
Knight ORF with Bishop G5 wow okay now
this is a real party here I mean you
play the bishop G5 night orphan you're
looking at variations that are easily 20
25 and 30 moves deep and I remember
getting caught in a terrible terrible
trap ages ago with my dear friend Jim
Tarzan Jim and I were preparing him for
competition
the interzonal and in the field was one
left polygayevsky and Lev played what
was called the polygayesky
defense to the nidor yes
and we spent the better part of half a
month
seriously studying this position Queen
C7
and we couldn't refute the variation uh
we couldn't refute his variation and
many many players tried and I could say
that this was actually the Tavia
position and you just look at the
position you go
chaotic mess
uh I must say that I miss love because
nobody plays his variation today I think
uh it's it's funny you mentioned because
all pictures openings before the engines
were so much more interesting right now
you put that position on the engine it
will tell you triple zeros or one zero
and you can't play it anymore exactly
Bishop G5 uh again E7 E6 F2 F4 uh and
there was Bobby Fischer's favorite the
poison Pawn today a lot of the players I
I see are playing the poison Pawn with
the inclusion of H7 H6 and they do it
for very very very specific reasons I
can assure you uh but you really really
need to know uh your stuff so much
Theory here yes I was starting this
opening like 15 years ago and even back
then there was so much Theory exactly
and it just keep exploding too players
keep adding more and more to this and
right see that was my problem actually I
started out as an E4 player but then
there would be people who specialized in
the night or or Marshall Gambit or
dragon and I felt when I was playing E4
I had to be prepared for all of these no
it was just it was just an overwhelming
amount is that when you switch the C4
exactly uh is it was this my my only way
of surviving the opening was to uh and I
wanted to say along with E7 E6 Knight B8
to D7 this was a variation I really I
want to say Boris gelfand more than
other players kind of champion Bishop to
D7 the reason I always thought it was a
little bit suspicious was because of
Bishop C4 a lot of these variations
white is looking to sacrifice a piece on
the E6 square but uh well nothing new
Under the Sun here as the players uh you
yeah thousands of games in this in these
variations and Almera I'll uh I'll toss
the ball over to you what a game has
caught your fancy uh yes sir please have
a look at this position
[Music]
um
a very unusual opening occurred first of
all here
who is playing with white pieces against
Alexandra Costino after an invitation to
play the nimitzu and then so she played
Bishop F4 and here I was expecting
Alexandra to play a very classical move
D5 because I happened to study it also
her husband's games because it's very
important in order to understand
professionals opening a repertoire and
Alexandra went for a more aggressive C5
and after D5 it is another invitation to
play the move B5 in style of Volga
Gambit or the benko and here
the position is already very complicated
on the Move four so let's say how should
white react in this position
they would play
Knight F3 then it takes D5 it takes D5
and I was looking at the very natural
move Bishop B7 attacking the pound on D5
so you cannot play Knight C3 because
before simply wins the central bomb
and how do you defend it actually that
you give away another Central pound you
play E4 and after Knight F4 an amazing
move Knight C3
so I think that Nana actually sorry uh
he's hoping to get this position so
because computer evaluates this position
already is
well much better I think for white even
though it's slightly better it changes
its opinion but why its initiative is
simply tremendous so let's have a look
what happens if black doesn't play
Bishop B7 here there are a few games
played by the professional so you
transpose
in a type of benoni position here after
D6 so how can it continue here E4 once
again but now the B5 Pawn is hanging so
the bishop and F1 can't actually can
actually take it and black plays E6 so
with a very complicated game but
computer favors white already here at
the move
six so after A4 he claims that white has
a huge Advantage well like some Echoes
of a Blumenfeld Gambit with the Bish
before and we were interested in their
head to heads uh match up here we have
it wow they've played a lot of games and
Alexandra has quite a lead she she won
11 times lost only four times and they
have 12 draws as well yeah a lot of a
lot of games help me out here Almera
because you know me I'm a pond grubber
after Knight F3 if I take the pawn on C4
just taking the pawn on C4 I'm assuming
the move Knight C3
yes yes B take C4 and of course a very
important move in this position is
Knight C3 right because Knight is very
stable now in C3 there is no more
um of course okay but then I I want to
follow up with uh I would love to take
twice on D5 and play Bishop B7 but my
Bishop's not going to be protected on B7
so I'll start with the move Queen B6 and
in my mind's eye I want to take twice on
on D5 so I can go Bishop B7 but also I'm
I'm hoping to distract you uh and attack
the pawn on B2 so Queen uh B6 I assume
it's all Gambit style from here you
continue E4 you're
Queen V6
is a novelty which is not a good sign
yet
yes uh people aren't they don't
understand my Fearless attacking style
I'm underappreciated but historians will
correct the record uh E2 E4 E2 E4 of
course and I grab because that's what I
do queen takes B2 green stick well there
are a few moves I don't know which I
prefer most here but a very calm Bishop
D2 Bishop D2 and by the way once you've
played the move Bishop D2 then we
actually transpose I saw some games
suddenly and rather remarkably uh popped
up in the database at the moment you
played this with the black pieces in
1988. see he used to be Fearless
at one time in his career uh I suppose
it was because he was playing in an open
tournament and in those open tournaments
you have to score so much okay I'm two
pawns up I want to maintain the pawns I
will go Bishop A6 to maintain the pawn
and
I agree I'm taking a very big risk as
black but I'm thinking if my opponent
hasn't prepared it maybe my opponent
gets nervous that the two pawns down and
and could it work what's the evaluation
the evaluation is almost plus free plus
three yeah why what am I missing queen
A3 it's just that I think that you will
be having a lot of troubles finishing
your development
after Queen A3 yep most the computer
suggests 95 or queen C2 he gradually
takes the pound on C4 uh solidifies the
center and then simply plays on let's
say what do you do after Knight E5
right B5 no Knight E5 because oh Knight
E5 I'm sorry threatening to win your
queen
well that that sounds you should give us
serious
and when you said threatening to win my
queen that is uh yeah okay and the two
Bishops that's so if I start running
backwards I'm going to be chased into
Oblivion huh yes run for your life
uh five and knights or four you know you
will have to give up one of those
Bishops I think and also have a look at
this thread you if you will play Bishop
B7 let's say I will always play D6 and
E5 is very absolutely okay I can even
play Bishop before back here yes that's
very very powerful I uh once you played
the move Knight E5 I was even
considering a little bit Desperado
Knight takes E4 okay and if tonight
takes E4 takes on D5 but I stop myself I
saw 94 Queen F3 and I thought urero uh
something has really gone wrong here for
black after uh 94 Queen F3 but even
after 94 I think that ed5 doesn't work
at all because here you have a more
useful move Queen H5 yeah oops yes and
then Knight F6 is coming you know
there's
while you're in Dire Straits totally
totally well this is uh
let's say uh sometimes I got caught with
my hand in the cookie jar uh going uh
Pond hunting and that looks like an
example of uh some some debacles let's
just say that I've had so at this moment
after Knight F3 uh Alexandra has
actually been uh
thinking which may not be the best sign
she was the one who played B5 after all
herself and the fact that she doesn't
have a a quick follow-up to the very
common Knight R3 is a little bit of a
bad sign now Mira yes and
because we are analyze the line with
ethics D5 it takes D5 let's have a look
at Queen A5 check right a very typical
Blumenfeld yes there's going to be a
very sound alternative in this position
but then simply Knight C3 in this
position so if you take on C4 we'll get
to the same position and you didn't make
a very useful move Queen A5 here exactly
so here maybe you will take on D5
because you provoked Knight C3 already
so maybe you will have to play B4 here
so
cd5 this was a game played by Navara
David Navara quite a while ago but
against a much lower opponent so that's
why I suspect this is not a very precise
play for by white so after B4
computer still thinks that white is
better here so he suggests 94 and even
if blacks plays D6 you know after E4 he
claims that white has quite a bit quite
a big Advantage so let's have a look
what happens actually after Knight E4
because I think that we are going to see
a lot of the positions where white
sacrifices the Central Pawn
um
for a long-term initiative and what can
you do here Bishop D3 once again it's
very surprising that computer makes
those Quiet Moves of course it wins the
tempo you attack the Knight but you
finish your development and after Bishop
D3 if you go Knight F6 then simply
castle and after Bishop B7 you play
rookie one and the computer the value is
this position is completely winning for
white even though black is the power nap
wow but way behind in the development
and
It is Well I cannot give a very useful
advice here after Queen C7 and I take C5
and I take C5 even C1 yes what a move
Knight 65. a brilliant idea here right
yeah no this is uh an example of uh
great development in the gambits uh over
overwhelming
um the materialist so
B5 uh
I'm not sure this is really paying uh
dividends for black because all the the
lines that you've been showing Almera
are pretty one-sided white keep
sacrificing material and keeps winning
the the lines you're showing and uh what
is I think the most
important the most the important factor
to consider is that nanergic needs is in
her element in those types of position
and this is very dangerous yeah if I can
ask also another question is okay after
night if Alexander captures on D5 takes
on D5 and we've been seeing her fall
behind in development when she's playing
moves like Queen A5 check what about
Bishop B7 and trying to lasso the pawn
on D5 is it simply D5 D6 is the issue or
no that's the line I showed at the very
beginning yes you still play E4 here
nonetheless E4 let's have a look once
again yes what happens after Knight E4
and I showed you this very surprising
move Knight C3 that's right so Knight
takes C3 yep USB takes C3 and then black
makes this move to protect the pound and
he's 6 and this is already a novelty
let's say I have only two games here
where humans played Queen A5 defending
Defender
C3 pound which is a very logical move to
me so Queen D2 was placed yeah I like
this move but now when you develop your
Bishop on E7 you have a lot of options
you can play Rook B1 attacking the B5
pound D6 at some point Bishop D3 and no
one is actually defending the monarch
yeah
um
very very double-edged stuff I I really
I wouldn't want to walk into it uh with
the black pieces especially uh without
some serious uh preparation and I don't
like this position uh for black I think
that uh it just it it it's too I'm too
far behind in development I'm too risky
and I'm really surprised that Alexandra
is still thinking because normally when
you go for this line you're supposed to
Blitz out the moves exactly that's
exactly right uh move Knight F3 has a
completely Frozen her let's uh jump to
the game of Bella again this was going
to be our Marquee match-up game because
of the number of points between these
two against A7 A6 yeah he already made a
novelty Queen B3 Queen B3 so I don't see
any games coming up
I suspect it might transpose once we put
some moves into the position so clearly
uh Bella is eyeballing the eve the B7 as
well as the D5 pawns and seeking to
provoke maybe C7 C6 in the near future
so if we play to move like for example
Knight F6 and we played Bishop G5 we
played Bishop E7 I suspect in a very
near future we could have some games pop
up and that's exactly what's happened
yeah
uh but why play Queen B3 so early
that is a very good question and I don't
even have a very good answer for you
because the only reason I could imagine
the queen uh comes out very early is
that you get some lateral Pursuit you
know with the bishop 2005 maybe black a
white squared Bishop to develop
right
um maybe imagine this imagine we were to
play Bishop G5
and we would go to a play night here
upon here Bishop to D6 okay okay Bishop
to D6 and if our Queen was already on B3
that Bishop wouldn't be going to D6
um otherwise I just don't uh see a major
difference why Queen B3 should be
preferred over uh minor pieces normally
speaking we we developed the minor piece
early and then we decide where our Queen
is going maybe our Queen is going to A4
maybe it's going to D2 so we'll keep an
eye on that and um
you have a different position on your
board
yes I'm analyzing the game between Arena
crash and Harry Katrina Valley and I was
actually surprised by irina's last move
A4 because I know this position a little
bit and I thought that you were supposed
to trade those nights and actually now I
had to look at the database and that A4
has been played a few times and it's the
second best move in this position so I
was not familiar with this idea so Irina
instead of Knight A4 here which trades
the knights and well if you take 94
Queen F4 you win a temper attacking the
pawn on A7 so King B8 and then
you can improve your Rook you can play
Rook C1 with a very positional play but
here Arena made the
very aggressive move A4 so let's have a
look what is the difference between 94
frustrated Knight and A4 because when
the Knight jumps to C4 you still can
play let's say I just wanted to
demonstrate it B3 because of Knight A3
of course so
this is a very important tactical Motif
for
probably so I suspect that after A5 the
black will always play Knight C4 so here
you had a few games where black played
Queen before natural yes because now
this square is becoming available so uh
how can white continue they still follow
the path which which was paved by a few
players so Bishop E2 King B8
and now Knight E5
so it's a bit mysterious to me ah then
you want to play 93 Knight C5 you know
kick the queen away and Knight C5 and A5
okay this is a very interesting plan
we do have Queen B4 on the board as you
were speaking
um harika just played Queen before
interesting move Bishop D3 I when I when
I saw the move A4 for the first time I
played this position in my practice as
black
nobody played A4 Against Me by the way I
thought the idea was going to be king A2
and queen B3 but if you if you imagine
that the Knight jumps quickly to d three
that's a Tempo and the Knight on C5 will
be excellent
and that actually explains the move
Bishop B2 because I've seen this
position for the first time in my life
as well yeah this is such a mysterious
move Bishop B2 after Queen B4 right and
then everything becomes uh crystal clear
the mysteries of the position or Unravel
is unraveled in front of us is 95 and 93
right so again for my uh perception the
night on G7 is doing nothing so I would
be trying to get the Knight into the
game Knight D6 Knight to C4 and then
after the move Knight E5 I I don't have
the time for night to D6 because of
Knight D3 I'd start to look at Knight C4
with the idea of Knight A3 check
um now maybe King eight two or do you
want to try to win the pawn I'm
wondering like you lured the pawn to C4
Knight takes 94 or do you like King A2
yeah King A2 might be a blunder because
there's 95 and D4 check oops you are
right King A2 does look like we walked
right into a discover check oops so
right so we no King A2 in that case so
maybe Knight Bishop takes her Knight
takes Knight takes let's say right
um
interesting how has their big games huh
how did the how what does the theory
suggest Almira um it um it's a recent
Theory because
because right Knight C4 here and I think
that White's idea is to take on C4 well
if you take with Queen C4 then you
simply
um yeah so many tempests in the opening
this it can't be justified simply so
where do you go here Queen A6 but if you
take D tax C4 here then white has such a
powerful Center and this bishop is
actually quite passive even though that
you know white has weakened a lot of
light squares so I think that this is a
very good option here to take
to take on C4 and there have been four
games which were played like this right
and let's have a look so Queen B4 yes
Bishop B2 I think that there was one
game played with your movie as her
Knight E8 here but this was the game
played between uh on the amateur level
and it continued like 95 then let's try
Knight C4 here so this is this would be
already The Naughty But actually here
the computer changes his mind her mind
and takes with a knight
so Knight C4 D takes C4
and even F4 while I will be cautious
about making this move immediately so
yes I would actually make a more human
move E4 here because you can follow up
with F4 of course but G4 looks uh very
harmonious in this position to me well I
like the big Center as well uh we'll
keep an eye on this one Alexandra after
a long thing by the way she really
wasn't sure how she was going to
continue the position after Knight F3
did Play Bishop B7 one of the
theoretical moves and we've been seeing
our chess engine just happily
sacrificing pawns with music engines
just hate benoni and Bangkok yes exactly
benoni's benkos and Kings Indians really
get a negative always plus one always
yes so Bishop B7 and I wanted to
check in with the
so after
um G6 is after 198 to D7 Queen E2
Queen E2 okay
uh already a little bit for me off the
Beaten Track H6
whoa H6
yeah I was thinking that uh the natural
follow-up for me would have been G5
Bishop here E7 E6 and this probably you
know tons and tons of things
something quite similar but the opposite
in a sense they play E5 and G6 instead
of G5 and E6 okay so G7 G6 and uh dragon
naidor for uh what do you call it the
dragon door for you yeah G7 G6
F2 F4 and wow
um
let me put it this way this seems to be
in the razor sharp modern stuff it's not
in the dusty part of my chess library
what's going on in this crazy game a lot
of games played here hundreds and
hundreds really how does it how does we
take I assume uh yes and then after it
takes e can you guess the next move
we're living the night hanging on D4
we're not castling we are castles Castle
yes okay we're living life on the edge I
can feel this so the idea in this case
is that and he captures will be met by
E5 and black has issues okay fair so you
can't Castle oh you can't capture sorry
turtle and Castle I think Queen C7 is
the minimum
seven
now do we move our knight move our no we
I like I like that this five is an
option but I think um 95 takes I think
Knight B3 is more common
wow great stuff Knight B3 is more common
now I'm assuming we've got to develop
right Bishop B4 Bishop B5
just just forget about the king side for
now wow
um whoa I see I see B5 and I I don't
know don't ask me why but Rook takes D7
Knight takes D7 Knight D5 uh is with a
purpose there isn't it oh boy
so lots and lots of games even here yeah
yes
and let's see how these two uh perform
head-to-head
well they've played 10 times already
four wins for zhensaya one for Brunei
and five draws four wins that's pretty
impressive actually
an advantage as zensaya so F2 F4 E5 on
the board and takes takes
castles
um if I'm not worried about you're
taking my knight could I Castle right
away I mean for for reasons that aren't
apparent to me I'd like to keep F4 takes
E5 in reserve
um
is this still yeah I think I see some
games have pop up so castles is also uh
completely playable as well the reason
why I might want to defer I'm always one
of those players that I don't like
giving my opponent options
so when I play the move tags tags
castles I'm giving my opponent an option
Bishop B4 that if the pawns remain on
the board
there's no Bishop B4 so I I
try to cut down the possibilities that
my opponent has uh
castles I agree with you I think in this
line most of the time Bishop become
Bishop's going to be fiancarlo on G7
right so Black's not concerned about
having Bishop before option exactly
exactly uh razor sharp stuff I must say
jump to Nana's game actually yeah Bishop
B7 she played E4 and so now none is the
one sacrifice in the opponent instead of
accepting a free Pawn on B5 exactly e to
E4 Knight takes E4 on the board and I
assume she's going to follow up with
the very natural move Bishop D3 give me
the Knight and if you take this is where
the computer has actually been just
simply destroying me uh the the threat
of rookie one and uh very very bad
things happening
um seems to be overwhelming right like
these positions the computer is going to
give me a plus three advantage or
something absolutely crazy but it's
still not that easy to play at the board
even if computer says plus three right
oftentimes it's by walking a very narrow
path speaking of the Narrow Path Almera
it's one of those games that is one of
those positions that's so sharp neither
player can really deviate but how does
the engine evaluate how does the Oracle
evaluates E4 yes we saw that E4 is the
typical idea in this opening but somehow
the computer suggests it's in a very
precise situation some black takes on G5
or queen A5 and then Knight CS3 but here
have a look nana jaganinze has already
played this position she deviates from
her own game in in the previous game she
did play Knight C3
here it doesn't want here's Knight C3
she played this game against Anna music
one of the top players in the world so
after ed5 Nana took on D5 Knight D5 but
here you have a very interesting
possibility which is the top line of the
computer is to take on B5 so you
threaten Knight D6 Knight C7 with a very
complicated place so I am actually
thinking what happened so that Anna well
Nana played
here E4 which is a novelty according to
the database yes and after 94k a
computer thinks that if you don't
include the move ed5 cd5 and you do not
open the e-filed it black is slightly
better of course this might change a few
moves later when uh it will understand
that the initiative
there will be enough compensation of it
for the pound and the initiative whites
initiative is too strong and even now
as you can see he well he decided to
propose the move Knight CS3 and a very
surprising Bishop D6
so
let's see who analyzed this position
better right so the the big difference
is by not opening up the e-file by not
including the move E6 takes D5 black is
Justified in grabbing the pawn on e4 you
can go back and let's say after castles
just avoid opening up the e-file with
e68t5 I guess you also got to be
concerned that the second Pawn can be
lost C4 takes d uh right behind in
development right he's considering
Bishop D6 first and Bishop D6 was a very
nice move
yeah it's a touch right so Bishop E3 and
now native six I think
oh you get the bishop to D6 with a tempo
so on Bishop G6 still coming to grips
with this position you know I'm a pawn
Grabber but you know I'm very very very
reluctant to fall so significantly
behind in development uh very
double-edged position I feel yeah it
doesn't even look like Black's that far
behind like one move away from Castleton
yeah after the move uh Bishop D6 is the
key though so I and how is that
different from Knight C3
Bishop DC here I thought white could
play Knight takes E4 and then take on C5
maybe I see
that's a big difference that's a Tempo
yeah there's some Queen A5 check still
some some variations to analyze I'm sure
which one's better now I know yeah
Knight on uh Knight D2 is not uh that
much fun uh good stuff we'll we'll
definitely keep an eye on this one I
just wanted to check in on Bella and uh
how that game and uh developed from uh
oops that's the wrong game this yes it
was just uh that's what I I I thought
that we would just see Knight F6 and ic3
in a kind of a transposition so that
game is actually unfolding very very
slowly the arena game that was the queen
B3 and check it out I played this
interesting move A1 instead of Bishop B2
that we're looking at
looking at after Queen before King A1
wow and now Bishop E2
hmm
okay I can imagine that the reason for
in this position King A1 is she's
anticipating Knight C4 so she goes King
A1 Knight C4 would actually be just a
bad move now go away with the queen and
uh I will play b2b3 and go away with the
Knight so King A1 stops Knight C4 King
B8 very very useful move I must say
Bishop E2 and again maybe also on Knight
C4 maybe Arena wants to play B3 maybe
that's why she played King also yeah
again just to sidestep this thread
and also ask Knights
exactly kind of like asking also the
queen what are you doing on B4 and then
following it up with uh B3 uh intriguing
is King A1 a novelty by the way what is
the novelty here
I think so after King A1 games in the
database disappear disappear they're
only been
um four four games and they're all
Bishop E2 I must say I I like uh the
inclusion of King A1 because of this uh
this Knight C4 was bothering me often
time as I was capturing it on C4 but I
do like this idea of just kicking
Black's pieces back with Knight A2 and
b2b3 and um well uh harika what's our
clock situations by the way
um
harika has hour and 15 minutes and Irina
has hour and 23 so I think Irina has
seen this position before and she's
quite well prepared
sure sure feels that way Bishop E2 nice
so uh games are developing really really
enjoyable and Almera which one
caught your attention well actually I
wanted to show you a lovely idea from
this opening now that while we start to
grasp all the nuances of this position
I'm thinking was the A4 the invitation
to play Queen before you know we started
to like the irina's positions more and
more but let's say we play
Knight E8 here and we actually allow
white to play A5 sure
so King A1 of course was the novelty in
this position so let's say A5 97 White's
idea actually is to play A6 and that's
why black plays Queen before not to
allow this uh plan with A5 A6 and if you
play B6 here well you can play Knight B5
you know and the computer thinks that uh
images white is completely winning
because you're threatened to take the
pawn on A7 and the pound on C6 so that's
the whole idea
of the move A4 and that's why black
played Queen B4 so King A1 is an actual
novelty in this position and I thought
maybe H5 was a useful move in this
position I don't know
try to create a little pressure pressure
on the king side but Knight E5 is still
very good for white here yeah it defends
G4 in a nice way oh but here maybe you
should consider Knight D7 once again you
have to trade the most active piece
which is the Knight on E5 and while the
Bishop is still on D3 you don't have
this D3 Square so let's have a look but
harika played King B8 and now Arena
proceeds with the original plan Bishop
E2 and now we know that she's going to
play Knight E5 and Knight D3
let's
see what do you actually do after Knight
C4 here
he's still he still considers Bishop C4
D takes C4 and E4
so and can you play if you played King
A1 can you actually play B3 in this
position that was my question so maybe
this is also irina's idea because after
Queen A3 you have Queen NATO sure of
course but then I'm not sure okay so
let's say 96 here
and Knight A2
a tricky move so white is definitely
better in every line and maybe Arena
also has the psychological Edge in this
in this game because she probably out
prepared her her opponent exactly no it
feels it feels wrong to have Knight on
G7 it's like Bishop should be interested
exactly and they're Head to Head uh I'm
sure they played each other yeah there
you have it 13 draws five wins for Irina
three for harika but 13 draws stand out
okay certainly do
nice uh good good good
contests I must say between the two uh
for me it's strange that the computer
after Bishop E2 would consider capturing
the Knight because I I really like just
driving the Pieces away night A2 if the
queen dropped back
B3 and it's sort of like well you've
helped me get in my whole beef A5 A6 a
concept
previously shown To Us by Almera I just
weakening or
softening yeah
with Tempe absolutely so yeah this looks
well good I I wanted to ask about
Alexandra's game again
still thinking after United Knight takes
E4 and a stop huh
it it does seem strange to me that
Knight C3 between 93 and Bishop D3 yes
exactly so but in in both cases Knight
C3 Bishop they're both being met by
Bishop D6 yeah actually I think Knight
bd2 leaves more logical than Knight C3
okay
but the same idea black is still playing
somehow it's the universal Panacea cures
everything you just play Bishop D6 you
attack my knight I attack your Bishop
uh plenty white could also play Maybe
Queen D3 instead of
just to not allow Bishop D6 I was trying
to think of a move that stops that
wouldn't welcome Bishop D6 yeah well I
grabbed the pawn and I Retreat maybe the
queen is actually in the way maybe I can
take on E6 and then on B5 now allowed D5
and let's play that position yeah but
this is like a bloom without Bloom and
fell Gambit where black really uh is
pleased because uh they're not even a
pawn down and you do get this massive
Center
first we played Bishop E7 I can also
cast along very quickly
wow that's taking your life into your
hands because uh with the pawn on B5 I
do have ways of opening up your
King's position with the pawn yeah it's
just a super devilish yeah it would be I
would be scared if I was uh White on the
white side of this queen D3 yeah I
understand what you're saying and now so
you're looking for a way of avoiding
this move Bishop D6 but if you were
gonna go for that let's let's just put
this on the board for a sec because
somehow this is
logical I would say takes takes yeah and
at least in this particular position I'm
not Material behind why not take so I
know typically black text with the F
Pawn just so they can play D5 but here
let's stick with a d-pawn sure okay and
still have exposed right Bishop takes H7
she bows yeah you you know who you're
sitting next to right because I will
take that pawn and I'll take your knight
with a discover check
um
kind of like night on D6 here yeah it
does it looks okay and you always have
C4 is a way of neutralizing and trading
um I don't see any real problems for uh
Alexandra in this case over to you
Almera what if you uh discerned about
this position well we are still debating
yes we haven't reached the state of
Technology technological singularity yet
but I have a few funny positions for you
because I'm smiling myself when
analyzing it simply so 94 and I I
started to analyze the move Knight C3
first because I think it's one of the
most critical moves in this position so
what if Bishop D6 then 94 Bishop F4
everything is quite forced so after
Knight C5 attacking this bishop and B7
uh the computers are just this move and
of course can get to here of course of
course of course this is very obvious
that's true and as you can see the
evaluation changes perfect zeros and uh
the position is incredibly complicated
at the move 10 already so this is one
option so what if black doesn't play
Bishop D6 here as it said just before
what if I say concentrate and I think
that
and none is trying to calculate
everything in this position and to
evaluate where you should go into
into like after beat the accessory so uh
here Bishop B7 I think that you want to
Castle Bishop D3
and another critical position after it
takes D5
and C takes D5 Bishop D5 here the
computer suggests another very logical
move so you're simply sacrificing
everything here and after 95 it as it is
the evaluation changes once again so we
are this is the move 11 here so it's in
between equal and
and equal and so let's say what is the
idea after Knight E5 and let's say if
you don't play nature 6 95 and 86 let's
say you play like a move which passes
here so this move is suggested yes a lot
of tactics in this position yes and it
and it is really very interesting but
the key to this position is that you
will have to sacrifice another pound
so it's not only the pound on e4 it's
you have to come up with the follow it
and sacrifice the pound on D5 as well
right
one after the other after the other I
I'm just just Charmed uh as we have a
standings reminder right we have Anna
Satoshi let
us have Biro that's why we don't have
her game so her score is going to be
frozen today Elizabeth pets in the clear
second herb by rounds coming up so uh
Elizabeth with a victory would be tied
right and sharing third Alexandra Casino
those suppliers already had their bus
right I was just Charmed by the position
that Elmira was showing us if I had
looked at games or collection of games
or annotated games from let's say uh the
time that I started playing chess if the
annotator had written Knight C3 Bishop
D6 Knight takes E4 Bishop takes F4
Knight takes C5 Queen A5 check King E2
with
crazy complications we would all agree
but today they would say in completely
equal position
triple zeros you're like who is this
annotator get this guy out of here you
know but no King E2 triple zeros as
opposed to uh absolute Chaos on the
board that's that's crazy by the way we
did have Bishop to D3 by Nana and this
is the moment where we're expecting
Bishop D6 by Alexandra I'm assuming that
there's something terribly bad about the
move Knight F6
um Almera because at the moment I don't
see it myself well there is nothing
immediate but the computer thinks that
after Knight C3 actually a white is
already much better so you can see the
evaluation changes dramatically so I
think that this possibility of
but developing the night on C3
immediately and while you're still stuck
there and one important point is that
when your Bishop is only seven and your
knight is on F6 you will always lose
your Bishop after castle and I think
this is the element the key element why
the computer evaluates this position is
much better for black because you you
have to find a way to finish the
development here and I'm not sure that
you want to take on C4 and to have this
position after Bishop C4 is you might as
well take on D5 so Knight D5 exchange a
few pieces so Bishop D5
Queen A5 let's try before for fun wow
yes
actually before what is the idea I
wanted to show you so like this of
course your that's why we Outlook the
queen so you will have to sacrifice yes
that's why you need to play before
otherwise so here what happens if you
take on D5 it reminds me of a line of
Volga Gambit so a lot of pieces are
exchanged and but here after Knight C6
well do you Castle here or what oh he
even suggest Knight G5 but I think what
happens after Castle
again it just feels like great
compensation Alexandra agrees with the
computer Bishop D3 was met by Bishop D6
and it didn't take her long to find
Bishop D6 either I think she just
recognized that the position after
Knight F6 Knight C3 uh White's got great
compensation in fact an advantage so
Bishop D6 kind of came pretty quickly
she was probably also thinking during
Nana's time absolutely uh Bishop D6 so
one of the things that I like to do and
I've kind of trained myself to do that
is while I'm thinking I'm looking at
tactics
I'm looking at sharp sharp forcing
tactics when my opponent is thinking I'm
trying to think strategically I'm trying
to think what are the good pieces what
are the bad pieces I'm coming up with
General conceptions but when my clock is
ticking I want to I want to look at the
sharp tactical thing so when you were
just talking well when Nana was thinking
maybe she was coming up with a bishop D6
keeping our eye on that one we're
getting close to our first break of the
day just wanted to go again to the
youths and to the youths in the
tournament did you ever see the movie my
cousin Vinnie no oh brilliant comedy
make an effort it's really good the
youths the youths castles Queen C7
Knight B3 of a position that you
anticipated B7 B5 on the board and
statistically speaking how how do the
players do fair from this position do
you know the statistics um I just know
that most common move here is 90
okay and well that's pretty forcing I
not nothing to say but I gotta take it
and I'm assuming I take it off and now
Bishop actually goes to D6 yes right
but I don't know the results I think
anything can happen
with all three results possible fair
enough all right an arena crash Bishop
E2 and herika is thinking and that was
the zinc style I like what Bella has
achieved
achieve the way oh she got an E4 E5 so
night see Knight F6 Knight C3 C7 C6 E2
E4 now we understand Queen B3 a lot
better
if for example you take on e4 then
Knight to G5 and Bishop C4 is Bella's
idea on each move we are discovering
more ideas behind couldn't be three
Queen V3 but maybe the move C7 C6 was a
little bit too compliant first invite
Bishop G5 C6 because Bella E2 E4 that's
a that's a great achievement for white
by the way sorry could black just take
is it possible to take Knight takes E4
Knight takes E4 94 and queen E7
at the same time
let's stop and think about this one so
you've also got uh a thought that was
going crossing my mind you you've got H6
here as well as other moves but the
thought that was crossing my mind is
that you do have Queen V4 check as a
potential bailout as well so Queen E7
let's stop and think about this because
uh
oh my uh you have Bishop G5 maybe right
I was about to say in for a penny and
for a pound Bishop G5
if you take yeah okay
I'm kind of happy I'm not sure I'm
ecstatic about my position but I'll play
F6 and take with the pawn on e4
wow and take with a Pawn on e4 and wait
are you losing a piece though maybe yeah
well of course but I I probably losing
I'll take your Bishop
I feel like I'm playing in some kind of
romantic era Paul morphy where just
please take all my pieces and I'm going
to win an evergreen game maybe not uh E4
by the way Elizabeth shied away from any
of the captures and she's just allowed
her opponent a very nice I want to say
positional Advantage I've got my Pawn on
E5
and after for example a 94 Bishop D3
Amira this is a a a a a question for you
what about this movie uh Queen E7 as
Nazi proposed well yes sir I wanted to
tell you that I'm actually so happy that
we can still have a discussion with the
computer and players can be creative so
Knight E4 I think is the best move in
this position but Bella has caught
Elizabeth by surprise so 94 Queen is
seven right a very important move the
follow-up so I think that Knight G5 can
be played here okay I protect the Knight
then F6 attack in the night Queen E3 is
take G5 Knight takes G5 so you get your
palm back so this this is a bit equal
but I don't think that uh black has any
problems whatsoever in this position
okay and also here I'm surprised
I was surprised that Elizabeth didn't
take GTX C4 because things are not so
simple here 95 Knight D5 I well I tried
all the human moves Bishop C4 Bishop B7
and the key to this position I think is
the move H4 because if you take on on e4
you know there's nothing really very
dangerous going on for black but after
H4 white is slightly better and well
keeping the pieces very active on the
board so but Nazi was absolutely right
94 is the best move in this position
followed by Queen E7 and Bishop G5 of
course you you can start with F6 maybe
bishop E3 here so D takes E4 then 92 and
maybe F5 for Bishop starts to you can
start with Bishop six here
quite the computer generated line you
really need to be prepared to go into
these variations as we get ready for a
break it's always a good time to stop in
and Shop with our friends at Q Boutique
and see what their specials are for
today today we have the 2023 Cairns cup
check it out men's jacket Karen's cup
men's jacket doesn't go hand in glove
but here you have it this is the
official men's jacket of the Karen's cup
chess tournament it is crafted from 100
polyester features the kieran's Cup logo
on the left breast and the St Louis
chess club logo on the back of the
collar stay comfortable stay stylish
while making your next move available
exclusively at Q Boutique St louis.com
check it out for all your shopping needs
and we're going to see you on the other
side of this break
[Music]
thank you
how does it feel to be here in San Luis
for the Third Edition of the Karen's cup
yeah I'm very happy I played first one
and after after break we are playing
like 31 and we're happy to be part of it
it's the strongest tournament in the
world with huge price on and I'm really
glad to be invited ah it feels good it's
my first time in us and in Saint Louis
so I really love the atmosphere and I
really love to bring you so I do look
forward to play as soon as possible
well it's great I was actually surprised
when I got the invitation because for
the second tournament I I didn't and I
was really upset so when I saw the email
I was very happy and I I mean I told my
parents like okay we're going to some
place again yeah I'm very excited and I
think this time it's a quite a different
field with lot of mix of egg players as
well and definitely this is one of the
strongest women tournaments and also
with the highest price fund ever
so I think it's going to be quite tough
for everyone I'm so happy to be back
here I mean I'm so happy that the
Karen's cup has resumed after a couple
of years you know
um of a break for the for the pandemic
and um yeah it's a very special
tournament I mean it was kind of
formulated to be one of the strongest
tournaments for women in the world and I
think it's going to be super exciting
I'm always very excited when I'm getting
invitation from Saint Louis and I'm
really very glad that I'm still here
after three years of break and yeah I'm
looking forward for a wonderful
tournament I'm really excited because
after three years we all are here and we
understood the value of it after
pandemic and to give importance that we
are here all healthy and playing the
tournament so definitely I'm really
excited that the strongest tournament
Karen's cup is back with the Third
Edition and yeah I'm looking forward to
be part of it so it's a long time I have
not been here it was 2018. my first
visit to Saint Louis and I had very good
memories despite of my playing so I hope
I hope that this year will be more
interesting games for me and
um I think well very well here I'm
delighted to the time here because I
like this club very much and this
atmosphere everything it's
um it's really nice to be here again
um first of all like I was very happy to
um receive the invitation almost in the
last moment because I think I was one of
the last participants to join the event
but yes I remember my time in 2019 even
so I think back this time I got the last
place not sure but I think so
um this time I hope I will do a lot
better I mean at least like to get
somewhere in the middle would be nice
and yes I am very happy that when I came
here today that I could recognize so
many things so nothing really changed
and it's still the same Spirit like
looking at the hall of fame
so I'm really excited to start actually
I'm very very happy and very excited I
was very looking forward to coming back
because we had this
um three year long Gap and you know
every single year we like got emails
about the possibility to be back and
then somebody didn't quite work our way
so I'm very relieved to be back and I'm
very looking forward to playing again
[Music]
hi everyone I'm here with Grandmaster
Nana dagnitze who just won her game
congratulations Nana a very nice game
today how do you feel being back at the
Karen's Cup in in the US and San Luis
yeah
I really love this place and whenever I
get the invitation I mean
I feel
very happy
so yeah this is my third time and
well I think it's everything is good so
I hope to continue like this I know
you've played a lot of tournaments
before coming here I was I was watching
the broadcast earlier
how do you train for these tournaments
how do you
stay in shape like work on chess and do
you have time to analyze your games in
between the tournaments or do you
analyze after yeah actually it's not not
that easy because I played very
important tournament like Grand Prix
last step because this tournament and
before that I played Armageddon in in
Berlin yes yeah and yeah yeah you really
need a lot of energy energy but yes and
I'm I'm trying I'm trying to
stay focused and show my best I mean I
don't have a choice because all these
tournaments can I play I love the story
so I cannot say no to I say is your
family supportive of your travels my
family is very supportive otherwise it
wouldn't be possible for me
I have two kids so yeah to pay support
that is great to hear last question I
don't want to keep you I want you to
have enough time to rest for tomorrow
you're probably still jet lagged from
Europe people wanted to find out on
Instagram about what is a like a meal
the kind of meal that you eat during
tournaments or what what kind of things
you enjoy to eat that give you the
energy either as you're playing or
during a tournament things that you
enjoy to eat if possible
avocado that's a great one what about
during the games do you take anything
yeah I take some snacks we have our
choice here during the game so
um
I tried to Sushi which is great and some
sweets okay
all right thank you so much nana I wish
you good luck in the next rounds and
we'll see you again soon
World Chess Hall of Fame located in the
heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the games the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
[Music]
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world-class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
[Music]
the muni's premier season bursting with
comedies romance and Magic Begins June
12th with the muni premiere of beautiful
the Carole King musical
the Epic summer continues with Disney's
Beauty and the Beast chess West Side
Story Little Shop of Horrors rent and
Sister Act
single tickets are now on sale at
muni.org
in Forest Park
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program in the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grand Master
varusia nicobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between at-risk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since 2019. the St
Louis chess club has also created a
chess merit badge for the scouts BSA
quickly becoming one of the most popular
badges with more than 200 150 000 Scouts
earning the badge since 2011. students
of chess can also pick up a copy of read
and write chess thanks to Club
co-founder Dr Jeannie Karen sinkfield
anyone can learn how to understand chess
notation in no time we've chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
standings after round six Anna
zatonsky's in the lead four and a half
points out of six games with Elizabeth
Pates could catch her because Anna has a
buy today
um and sharing third around Alexander
costume in Battlefield Michigan and
those players I apologize your mic's not
plugged in but I will tell you that in a
tie for third is Alexandra Bella harika
and er well pardon me Alexander Beller
typer third and tarika and Arena type
for fifth uh pairings for uh this round
seven uh underway by the way
nice they're all youth match up there
Irina Crush against Harry cadrona Valley
nanotech needs it against Alexandra
Costa nyuk and Bella for tennis really
against Elizabeth pets and in this round
seven there are some cutrol chest being
played let's just jump into the game
because there was this naidorf game I'd
mentioned Rook takes D7 like that
crossed my mind and that was actually
played and it was like yeah Rook takes
D7 sacrificing an exchange
um Zendaya played Rook takes D7 Knight
takes D7 and we're about to catch up
with the players Knight D5 Tempo against
the queen queen dropped back to B8
apparently this is all Theory
it really
strikes me as Cutthroat chess Bishop F6
give me The Rook well give me your
Bishop Knight takes Knight takes king d8
queen D2 check and I'm being told that
this is actually going towards a draw
what's the draw by the way 26 Queen D6
Queen A5 check yep
uh attacking and I guess I'm blocking
that one too Queen C7 yep Queen DQ and
queen D6 and that's how we get the
pipette black shouldn't avoid the
Perpetual because Bishop D6 was bad
probably Knight D5 or something
crazy question crazy variation and by
the way Queen D6 just played on the
board here
as step one the players might be heading
four draw it's one of those crazy things
about the modern chess as some of the
sharpest most double-edged games somehow
always seem to get to Triple zeros yeah
if both players know how to play
correctly all these ends in a draw it's
crazy stuff uh so that's an incredible
game uh also for me is the game of and
there we have a queen A5 check we might
be seeing a draw coming up on we can't
go to
I think they're about to repeat for the
second or third time yeah
Queen A5 check and again Queen C7 looks
forced Queen back to D2 check and let's
see if we can't figure it out for
ourselves Bishop D6 is probably a very
bad move is it Knight D5 that looks the
most obvious
so what's the threat with 95 let's say I
moved the queen oh you want to go back
to A5 yes exactly and it's not so easy
for you to find a good story thanks
Queen C6
Knight to D5 Queen yeah I was making the
wrong move for
for white though uh Queen C6 Queen A5
check Bishop C7 King
oh I can do Bishop system
and trade
is there a bishop takes I'm thinking
yeah Bishop takes B5 personally doesn't
work Pawn takes a takes B5 right
okay just a second maybe night before
here
night before it's it's a one movie
there's also Queen E7 right uh pardon me
Queen A3 here as well exactly it might
be just another one of those uh
repetitions we do have Queen C7 on the
board
uh
uh Queen A5 Queen D2 check it's inside
okay
um I think it's a a draw by repetition
yeah
and these two players uh Jean Zaya
actually hasn't won a game yet in this
tournament which is very rare for her
because she's one of those really really
sharp players you do expect her to have
a loss or two
but she'll also expect to have two or
three wins she's a big fighter and quite
an aggressive player yes exactly Queen
to D6
and we are going to yeah the repetitions
are pretty much uh in the bag now Queen
permanent Queen D6 Queen A5 on the board
Tom loves the handshakes our producer
loves to see the two players making
peace
I think now gunai could already claim
is it it's already been that fast and
queen C7 in situations like this I
always repeat another time and I want to
be sure to be sure oh you want your
founder to cling cool me I'm sure the
Arbiters
are ready to step in and accept
the claim by the way disappointing so
far seven rounds for both players and
they haven't uh
um they came into the tournament with
very high hopes I saw them at the
opening uh or the players meeting I want
to say and they were uh very uh pleased
to see one another and uh we're
expecting a draw here
and let's just jump to a marquee
match-up game between Bella and
Elizabeth because when we left it Bella
got in a very important break E2 E4 and
Elizabeth played Bishop E7 acquiescing
to a considerable space disadvantage
after the move E5
it was actually incredibly critical that
she played Knight takes E4 and there's
our handshake and draw in this game it
was actually critical collection she
played 94 in Queen of seven probably
tried to Finish Well since they didn't
start well they had two rounds to go and
yes they'll try to get some wins at the
end for their sake absolutely so this
was actually the key moment in the game
or the key moment in the opening is
after E4 Knight takes E4 Knight takes E4
Queen E7 was what Elizabeth had to the
essay because what she has right now I
wouldn't recommend to anybody she played
Bishop E7 E5 Knight D7 and you already
see the center is incredibly imposing
question after E5 could you still try
Knight E4 I thought again that that was
also a quite a critical move I mean it
might already be quite bad but right
it's 97 looks so much worse exactly at
least you could trade and deal with the
cramp position uh by exchanging off a
pair of knights instead Elizabeth played
Knight to D7 and then again after Bishop
D3 Knight to f8 she is really under a
great deal of duress I want to say this
Pawn on E5 Pawn on D4 very very
disruptive and everything I like
everything about White's position do you
like the next move H4 I do I do I like
this move in fact very much because it
basically says
I'm gonna be hunting your king if you
even think of ever stepping over onto
the king side I I I'm ready to meet you
h2h4 ideas also prepare some jobs to G5
with night or the bishop precisely so
and that is why Elizabeth played the
move h7h6 I would be as white V very
happy to play the move Bishop E3 which
as I was speaking Bella played she's
looking at castling
by the way this queen on B3 is
irritating for another reason the pawn I
mean all black piece only the bishop is
on the seventh rank every other person
is on the last rank yeah with a Fisher
random if we could put the queen on G8
and the bishop on d8 we would have
shuffled Exposition yeah we would have
shuffled the pieces yeah an indication
that uh terrible things have happened in
the opening I was gonna ask
for sure better for what took us
alongside because
well the move h2h4 doesn't go hand in
glove with gasoline I understand I
understand uh yeah I wouldn't say the
door is closed to such a concept of
castling short I actually like it in the
sense that long Castle allows more
counter play on The Queen side
I think black will have to throw the
pawns you're right B5 C5 whatever they
can do right if this F Pawn were uh
let's say doubled for whatever reasons
F2 takes G3 castling short would
certainly have my attention the half
open f file
castling short if you could get an F4
yeah by the way Knight E6 also once
again Elizabeth Intimates that she's
going to Castle
short
I don't know I don't think that's going
to work very well like if your Castle
short another reason why I really like
H4
oh nice
the old battery right Bishop will drop
back and when you play G6 I've got H5
Bishop takes H6 but H5 is what I really
wanted to suggest black weights and
doesn't Castle lives the king in the
center so after a long Castle just play
A5 with the plan to play in 86 Knight B4
and A4 is so awesome yeah do your best
to unravel makes a lot of sense to me uh
you you your squeeze for space so you've
got to figure out a way and the move A6
is actually in the way of the night so I
like this I just I just like it so much
more for white that I think black has
got a lot of repair work to do
um I want to invite Amira to jump uh to
join the oops uh sorry
Banana's game actually we have
D6 is where we left off right right
Knight C3 actually yeah that's right we
actually left off here uh Nana Play
Bishop E3
night drop back to F6 Knight to C3 go
ahead make my day capture capture and
instead Knight takes B5 we just caught
up with the players Bishop E7 on the
board
um I seem to like Black's position
because
Knight on V5 feels like it's going to
waste a template to come back
and the center
blockage control in the central with the
pawns exactly or will be at least very
soon after we exchange one pair of Pawns
and the other Pawn comes to D5 well it's
kind of funny because there's been some
chewing and throwing could I throw in
the move uh Bishop F4 just to eyeball
the D6 and would you take on C4 oh yeah
I think I'm gonna castle and let you
take the exchange
ah nice because I should have you know
more than enough composition I would
agree with that uh I would agree with
that so wholeheartedly I'd be reluctant
now especially when you're you're
inviting me to take the exchange it's
sort of like oh no I don't want it now I
don't want it now I'm having uh doubt so
Bishop E7 but on the other hand if I
capture and you capture I don't have
time for the desired Bishop E4 move E3
is hanging this looks like uh it could
rebound against uh white I mean one
moment I thought I was ahead in
development right now I'm no longer uh
sure but we're ready uh Almera with a
very special guest I don't think we can
get in
thank you yes sir yes I'm joined in the
studio by Alex gerford and his kids
yes you have to put your daughter on
your left so a little bit higher there
we go this little lady uh has ringed the
Bell tonight yes how did you enjoy that
so Alex you are this senior financial
advisor at Edward Jones
and I've learned a lot of things about
you that if you made a lot of
contributions to the world just cheers
and especially the community in Saint
Louis but you're also the founder of a
very important uh chess program and
chess tournament the Saint Louis
corporate chess League please tell tell
us a little bit about this yeah thank
you I'll I'll talk about the corporate
League I do just want to say first and
foremost that my relationship with chess
is definitely as a fan and so seeing the
Karen's cup back here again every year I
bring my kids and we really have a good
time being here so what um you know Dr
Genie and and Rex have done to bring in
the best talent is really exciting here
in St Louis and it really is amazing to
see the connections that the that chess
can have and so my idea around having
chess and corporations come together
about seven years ago has really taken
off it's been it's been amazing to see
here and see St Louis how much interest
that that people love networking
competing having fun over the game of
chess and so it was kind of an idea that
came up with a friend of mine and we
were talking about like corporate
softball leagues and I just kind of had
the idea well what about a corporate
chess league and from there was able to
share with the St Louis chess club and
they've taken it certainly to amazing
Heights where we have great competition
great organization of the tournament and
it's been a lot of fun
well you're the captain emeritus of your
own team so who actually won the last
season and tell us a little bit about
the next season and what businesses
participated before in them sure so this
season I have to tip my hat to our
friends over at Enterprise they won the
the 2023 spring spring league and Edward
Jones came in second place and then some
of our other other competitors were
Ascension Healthcare Enterprise
worldwide technology we had Charles
Schwab making their debut Reuben Brown
and then also the St Louis chess club
actually fielded a team this year so
eight teams participated in all and it
was a great competition but Enterprise
wound up taking the the top honors for
the spring season
key and then if other businesses want to
join what do they have to do it's it's
really easy to go on to the St Louis
chess club website and look under the
corporate chess League logo be able to
sign up and next season already we're
bringing on Boeing I think two other
teams have already contacted me and and
interested in it and so if if you're
interested in competing you know get a
team together of five or six people and
and come out it's a great opportunity to
not just the the networking side but the
relationship that chess can have with
strategic thinking problem solving
pattern recognition can really be
something that goes I mean across any
company that is going to be something
that will be good for your your
corporation and so encourage you to to
sign up and and come out and compete I
also said maybe bonding because it's it
can help it could be a team building
event absolutely I mean being able to
have some of those Fierce battles
encouraging your your colleague makes it
a lot of fun yes so let's have a look at
the upcoming events right on your screen
you have the the dates
of the of the next events 2023
fall dates
so we're on a little bit of a break
right now over the summer time but yes
get those uh get online sign up before
September 28th when the pieces will be
flying again we'd love to have more
teams more competitors the cross
industry idea sharing that just
naturally and organically comes out of
the corporate chess League time and
there's hey there's a few Refreshments a
few beverages that that we share as well
and so it really makes it for a good
time overall at the the corporate chess
league and I think that we are going to
have a replay of a very beautiful moment
where your daughter rang the bell and
but how did you choose it is
oh that's great well I mean being the
Karen's cup and getting to be here with
with our family I thought it'd be
appropriate and fun for my daughter to
get to step up there which they're both
excited that next week they they will be
here at chess Camp all week so they'll
both be here participating with that so
for those parents that are out there if
you're still looking for something for
your your young kids to do that's going
to benefit them over the summer time
um the the St Louis chess club camps are
are going to be a lot of fun so I assume
they both play who is who is stronger
we want to reveal this I think I think
I'll stay out of that one next question
well I have one last question for you
Alex that's I also know that you are
involved in the case such as Club can
you tell us more about that sure my wife
and I have been involved with the kaisa
club for a number of years now and it is
for those that are interested in
supporting the educational benefits as
well as the the cultural exhibitions
that we see here in St Louis where the
it's an annual gift of a thousand
dollars a year and as a result of that
gift you're really able to support the
the massive amount of student education
curriculum that the St Louis chess club
provides and there are some really
really cool things that you get to do as
well being able to go to some of the
opening exhibitions getting to go to
certain tournaments getting some behind
the scenes access at times and so it's a
great way to support St Louis chess and
and everything that we're involved with
here and we've really loved being a part
of it and getting to bring our family as
well to various events and so and kaisa
being I believe the the goddess of of
Chess and so historical it's kind of a
nice connection really cool thank you so
much thank you guys so looking forward
to play a game of chess against you
thank you thank you Alex and indeed I'm
happy to join you also at the Kaiser
chess club it's uh it's really really
wonderful we have a kaisa dinner for all
of the members here in St Louis and like
you said I mean supporting all the
programs that take place here in St
Louis is fantastic including all of
these uh summer camps and there are a
lot of them and including Gary Kasparov
too okay uh the Kasparov chess
Foundation supports children in chess
um I was about to say Bishop F4 was
played by Nana during this year well
yeah but it's it's about to rebound
because I really like your answer
castles I think that you know this
invitation to go Knight C7 sure it just
feels like uh this is the type of
position that could actually just be
incredibly good for black takes whether
it's it's D5 I'm just not a happy camper
here maybe one has something else
instead of knights of seven I certainly
hope so for an honest sake because this
is not looking good what do you could
you make us offer a movie Castle
yes okay although that
question comes why did we play Bishop F4
exactly because
blacks now we're a proud possessor of
the center and dare I say it yes as he's
she's got a pawn in hand as well
initiative Center pawn and hand
something's gone let's try it seriously
one more attempt maybe maybe bishop C7
Bishop C7 and
you're forcing me to move my queen I'll
pick this one right if you went to E8 I
would have castled if I go to E8 you
would have castled and maybe the reason
I didn't want to go to East it was
really a little reluctant to allow the
move Knight D6 and I wanted to give my
Rook okay that square okay I guess I can
still Castle here because on a six
Bishop D6 I don't think I'm losing a
piece that's about all the good news
that you could possibly share right uh
but if I just go for the conventional
stuff too like takes takes takes I think
White's hang in here by a thread very
very very uh
slim thread indeed uh looks like uh
Alexandra's uh I want to say risky
opening is paying off and the move
Bishop F4
may have set the tone for for the rest
of the game but did she have a better
move because the move that I was looking
at wasn't really that attractive for me
either could should she have taken and I
don't know played some
Alexandra just castle by the way
inviting Knight C7 yeah and that's
really a good move by Alexandra who by
the way won yesterday
I talk about Fierce competitors
check out that interview with Alexandra
after she was told that humpy withdrew
there goes my point she complained
she's still in the mix yeah she defeated
U.S number one Irina yesterday and she's
trying to defeat George's number one
today exactly with three points a
victory today would give her four uh but
what I wanted to ask you uh Nasi Bishop
F4 maybe that was mistined by Nana but
could you alternatives are not that
pretty either they aren't okay yeah
because I didn't really like what uh
options she had and and if we go shall
we go down this Rabbit Hole a little bit
if I go Knights he said seven I'm
assuming you're taking by the way
I mean
um you have other options yeah you do uh
developing a night
um do they have Knight H5
I might just Bishop not even give you
any material
oh dear oh dear I'm I'm coming to grips
with the idea Bishop H7 doesn't work
right Bishop G3 here welcome in Knight
G3 opening up H file that's a nice one
thank you very much yummy
uh I thought you were gonna take on G3
first exactly I was
it's my Fearless aggressive style you
see I just can't help but sacrifice
other people's pieces but you're
absolutely right that I could have
captured and in this case I've got at
least a draw
and uh Almera uh Knight H5 Bishop G3
um maybe Knight H5 isn't the way to go
uh what does the Oracle say
is happening in this game night H5 is on
my board and I analyze this position
actually I think that after Knight H5 if
you want to your bishop and to win an
exchange you have this move Queen Z2
so then well you could have taken on F4
but you can also take on C4 so then
Bishop B2 negative 4 Queen F4 and then
D5 white of course can't take the Rook
on A8 but after Bishop A8 black has such
a powerful Center the pair of Bishops
and the position is close to winning as
you can see is the evaluation I actually
wanted to show you where Anna went wrong
because
she was facing a very important decision
a tough decision here and that was the
only way where she could actually
exploit The Bishop's position on D6
because after C takes D5 I think that
Nana had to capture back on D5
why can't you take on D5 because after
Bishop D5 you can simply Play Bishop E2
and white is winning because both
Bishops are hanging and if you take on
F3 Bishop F3 is attacking the rook and
A8 and the bishop on D6
so this line will not work then if
Knight D5 doesn't work
Knight B5 will come with the temper and
I will win back the pound so what can
you consider here for black I think C4
is a very human move so here you can
play Bishop C2 and keep the the bishop
on the long diagonal as well so
the computer actually relates this
position is close to equal but I think
this was a much better than to what
actually happened at the game because
White's pieces are incredibly active the
bishop looks very strange now that black
yes has taken on D5 so and the Knight is
still on V8 you cannot develop it to C6
and the bishop and the pawn on B5 is
still hanging absolutely I that it was a
much better decision than the current
position because I'm looking at the
current position after Bishop F4 and I'm
just seeing very very uh clear advantage
for Alexandra especially these lines
where you just allow Knight C7 and the
the loss of an exchange but such a
powerful Center uh I I really like
Black's position a great deal I just
want to go through around the tournament
hall for just a moment Bella decided by
the way intriguingly after uh after
including the move h2h4 in her earlier
decision she decided that she's not
going to go along with her King a castle
long that is she played the move Rook C1
trying to do her best to discourage C5
A5 A3 Knight A6 again I really like
White's
space advantage and if I'm in White
Shoes this Knight on C3 is not really
working as well as I would like and
maybe on a good day I would
look to try to play Knight E2 to G3 to
F5 Knight on F5 looks Splendid to my
eyes so I really like Bella's position I
like Alexandra's position and then
finally uh
uh we go to Arena and her arika when we
left it we had just left it
these parts were 95 to D3 was on a
Arena's agenda she achieved what she
wanted including as well A5
maybe looking at outposts on C5 A5 takes
takes
H5 okay
um
I really like what Arena's done
everything looks uh to be in White's
favor at the moment uh passive bishop
and I also like the C5 Square I really
like this idea of playing Knight to A4
to C5 uh Queen
um B3 and the fact that I always have A5
A6 in the pocket to uh
I want to say loosen weaken the square
C6 I like what arena has done uh
what what about you Almira
indeed and I was just puzzled by the
computer evaluation because it's really
severe almost plus two yes let's say if
Irina plays A6 here this is a very
useful move anyway because in some lines
the C6 pawns will become a very
important Target so B6 and now this
spawn is quite weak so I think Rook D G1
okay attack in the bond yes of course
and
a very important move after Bishop F5 I
think is to play Bishop G4 you have to
exchange this Defender and then this
Pawn will will fall and that's why I
think the computer uh well has such a
high evaluation of this position because
he thinks that white is much much better
so what do you do here you will have to
play Knight G7 you certainly can take on
G4 because then you will simply double
your Rooks and that's it so Knight G7
here so Bishop F5
but here as you can see after Knight G7
you can no longer take like this and so
you have to take with the Knight on F5
and then well I was thinking what to do
here because now you cannot dabble on
the G file and that's why it was
important to play Knight G7 because
black is controlling the H file as well
so what do you do here yes sir actually
I think that here you're in need of a
human move right I I'm looking at the
pawn I'm looking at rook h8 and Knight
F4
it's a rookie cheat
Knight F4 ah yes that was the Tactical
actually short yesterday
exists in this position
it takes G6 yeah
four so Knight D4 there is a small
tactical shot I still think that maybe
you should go for uh it takes D4 because
what happens after exchanging on G6
Knight G6 can I play Rook G8 ah take
advantage of the pin yes and they should
take maybe I'm not sure at all because
they have
being able to cope yes I think that it
works and you simply take back the night
and it's around equal so maybe you
shouldn't rush with things here and what
computer is suggesting something like
Queen it too maybe he wants to bring the
queen on G4 so let's say something like
this that looks very nice let's say 97
and then Queen G4
I like this very much and here you go
you have your night F4 and well white is
clearly better here yeah in this game
this whole variation uh I'm I'm
questioning whether or not the move A5
A6 is so completely necessary I
understand we're softening up a C6
square but for for for reasons that you
know just my experience tells me I like
the fact that the Knight doesn't have
the B6 Square so the fact that the pawn
is on A5 already
maybe I'm reluctant to play Asics but I
think the engine really wants Arena to
play Asics yes he wants her to play a
six for several reasons of course he
softens the bound on C6 but I also think
that in some lines the back rank may be
a problem as well because you don't have
you no longer have this B7 Square so
right if you can combine the Strategic
ideas with some background mates and
ideas
yes okay I think it could be useful but
for example if you don't play A6 here uh
yes Rook G1 which Rook once again Rook
on D1 uh to G1 G1 and Bishop F5 once
again so we can have a look at the
different Bishop to G4 because
you know it's funny to play a move like
Bishop G4 trading off the passive Bishop
but the bishop on F5 is doing a great
job at defending as very weak tender
Target on G6 so Bishop G4 with
understanding I want to say yeah that's
actually interesting
the computer doesn't play Knight G7 and
here's and He suggests something like
Queen C7 first attacking the pound on A5
and here you don't actually have the
time to play A6 because this one can be
captured yes Queen A5 checks so let's
say King B1 that's not the end of the
world but I think that that's why it's
quite logical to include the move A6 and
you take away not only the square on B6
but also a lot of possibilities of Queen
C7 Queen's seven years Queen A5 so
let's let's wait and see I think that uh
this position is rather critical we have
the Knight H5 on the board right and
NASA join the conversation here for a
second so imagine that you were an
Arena's shoes you got this nice position
you've built up I want to say a better
Pawn structure and you've got this
Outpost for the taking Knight A4 Knight
C5 Knight A4 is very tempting exactly
right and I think she just made that
move as well she did okay so that that
was what and well what came to my mind
was I want to post up my night on C5
and the crazy part was the engine really
likes A6 B6 which takes away my natural
Outpost but for other very concrete
reasons
the engine calculates this as a very big
advantage
Pawn on A6 looks overpushed right it
even looks like I'm going to lose that
pawn it could be a potential liability
right so I understand why Irina didn't
think about A600 wait Knight A4 and that
was my question to you would you have
played A6 or would you have played the
natural for me the natural move was
Knight A4 A6 just looks like
it's too early to push A6 sorry no I
wouldn't have played it not without the
seeing the engine right right I mean it
makes fours of us at times because we
feel like Knight A4 Knight C5 we think
that the queen can go to B3 and and keep
your A6 option available for later right
that also looks good intriguing uh and
Alma
by the way Nana did Play Bishop C7 so
absolutely crazy position there too we
we might have three decisive results
come results come in well that would
only be typical for our event I mean
it's a 63 at uh at the start
um Almera was explaining to us uh the
overall result yeah overall total uh
decisive results after six routes is 63
but if we take a look at round two yes
100 and twice it was already 75 so yeah
we could be looking at one of those days
with a lot more decisive results and
Bishop C7 I did as did Alexandria
already play Queen she's thinking okay
Quincy does seem most logical right
absolutely and I think this is an
indication that Nana is realizing it it
didn't go well I mean this is just a
yes very much so uh she's sacrificed
upon for Gambit play but um Castle here
well indeed castles
A6 Bishop D6 right that's my only idea
indeed and I was
I I like sacrificing exchanges for
massive uh of Pawn structures
that's what I'm thinking that you
probably should not be reaching for the
Rook but on the other hand check this
out I've got Rook A6 as a potential
defense Robert yes the word I learned
from you yeah Rook up and over Rover I I
got it uh from Jennifer but I'm Jennifer
shahadi but I'm going to call him credit
for it because you know something
original I don't have much but that
already is in the K indication of
something going wrong but even without
the move A6 I could take on C4 and
played the move D5 and here I again I'm
really liking everything that I'm seeing
from White from Black's point of view
ready for Rook rook and okay I think
black's only problem in this position is
that they have too many options good
options yes exactly so a very very nice
position for Alexandra to be sure and
then let's go to Bella and Elizabeth and
once again boldly stating the obvious
Bella started with short castling losing
her first two opening games she wasn't a
happy camper but boy did she come
storming back she won three in a row she
got her buy that was the only way we
could stop her streak and she's looking
to make it four in a row and she's just
played the move 92 and I think this is a
very clear indication of what she's
looking for otherwise she played Rook C1
so no long hassle no longer she's not
even rushing to Castle short either
right at the moment
especially with a Pawn on A5 there's no
let's say disruptions Bishop B4 Jack or
queen A5 check it's interesting usually
when you have an advantage this early
yeah in the game you have an advantage
on one side or in the center and one
side but I think she's playing on all
three sides of the board and she has
advantage on the queen side Center and
the King side yeah
I once had a game with Victor Kushner it
was black and it was annotated by
Raymond Keen in the tournament bulletin
black is winning on the queen side
better in the center and winning not the
game side and that's kind of what I feel
like has happened in this game with
Bella she's much better winning in the
center better on the king side and well
better on the queen side so across the
whole board and this is last move on the
board
that just shows how desperate the
exposition is exactly I think that
Elizabeth
understood that
if she put her King
safely away on the king side the moment
you see this move Bishop B1 and queen C2
there's nothing safe about that King on
the king side so she didn't want the
castle do you think she's planning to
play G6 King G7 or just leave the King
on f8
really I do I think she's just actually
looking in survival mode at the moment
um she would like to play C5 but I think
she is understandably worried that any
opening of the position is going to
benefit white that the white species
will flood in so she really didn't want
to move her Bishop potentially just lose
the pawn on B7 for nothing she didn't
want a castle King f8 is a kind of a
temporary Rising move and the real
question for me is what will she do
after Knight G3 I was also thinking
maybe H5 just to not allow G6 in case
that's her idea and indeed and I'm
sitting there saying you know I would
like you to play the book Jesus yeah I
would be very happy because now after
age five you've got a you've got an
issue do you want to play King G7 and I
have to yeah and potentially allow uh
again as a as a commentator I will play
fearlessly I will sacrifice all the
pieces that they'll let you volunteer
all the time
but this is a very good section yeah but
this looks really really really good and
tempting so uh we don't see it uh uh
Almera we just think that Elizabeth
uh from the opening uh found herself in
a lot of trouble and she her position
nothing good to be said at the moment
for her position and she's in a lot of
trouble indeed because the computer
evaluation is
overwhelming yes overwhelming it's plus
3.4 but I was looking actually at a very
simple move because I think that if you
Castle black cannot take on H4 and of
course Elizabeth will not take an H4 but
just this simple variation illustrates
you how strong uh whites initiative is
after the move F4
so what what are your options after king
of eight and castle and as I suggested
G6 but now that the move G6 appeared on
the board you can play your move H5 so
and after Knight G5 I I really like the
move Knight H2 and then you can play F4
um Black's position is going to collapse
in a few moves here yeah it's almost a
dream position I would say for for uh
White so after Caso can you start now
that I'm anticipating all these ideas
with the move H5 then G6 and maybe
Knight G7 and try to hold in this way
let's say we will make a pass move maybe
G3 so maybe you can play G6 here
um some move just to illustrate the idea
King G2 and Knight G7 as you can see the
advantage is no longer
that impressive so maybe this is the
idea to stay in the game she definitely
has to consider H5 after Castle I say H5
indeed
um G5 Square was that were the chess
informant books important for you as you
were uh how do you say climbing the
ranks did you study the chess informant
yes I love those books you did yes
whenever the new version would come out
you were eager I'll tell my parents I'm
going to my room and don't bother me
right yes I love studying those and did
you
um uh memorize the code like what a
triangle meant and what a square meant
you you knew all of that good stuff and
my books were always highlighted so I
would go back and revisit what I learned
right those are very important books for
me too especially uh for for for for me
I studied them not religiously but you
get the idea but we thought there should
been uh an emoji a figure and we wanted
a pillow
a pillow like there was a the the
triangle better was a square a force
move and then a pillow what was the
purpose of the pillow
dream position and I'm looking at
Bella's game and I'm thinking of a
pillow this is almost a dream position
for white she's got the space in the
center she's got the better development
she's going to have the safer King a
dream position I guess the only thing
she doesn't have is an advantage on the
clock that's the one thing she's missing
and Almera what uh what's caught your
eye I was actually analyzed in the game
between
Alexandra questionna because I wanted to
draw your attention that Alexandra has
just played Queen E8 and not Quincy it
as you suggested Queen said of course is
a stronger move but from a human
perspective after Queen eight you know
the computer indicates that the best
movies C takes D5 but there are so many
variations that you have to come to
calculate where there is when maybe a
check on D6 you know this is not very
very easy for white to Simply to say
okay hey I will take the pound on D5 and
let's see what happened and leave a
discover check possible yeah and also I
think that here and especially Nana
stayed clearly indicates that she is
completely on tilt because I am not
afraid to use this term and that's why
she's playing in such a Chevalier risk
way if I might say but as you can see
the computer indicates that this
position is already winning for black
but let's see what can happen could
happen after Queen E8 so if you don't
take on G5 and if you Castle but then
you can take on C4 so Bishop C4 and
simply play D5
I think that you've analyzed a few
positions with a similar structure and
the centers so here there is nothing
much that you can do Bishop E2 you can
play A6 and drive the Knight away
and white white is upon down black has a
powerful Center so there's not much that
you can do here and then after Queen
eight
C takes D5 actually has to be considered
and that's the only move to stay in the
game so here I was thinking that the
computer was proposing C4 because after
Bishop c4u actually because I was
thinking at the beginning that you have
this powerful double check but this is
not it and
the computer suggests A6 and here now we
well he thinks that
and very rightfully so that black is
completely winning because now the
bishop is not protected so you can
easily win this with a discovered check
let's say queenetto and you simply take
the bishop
so after C4 you cannot take on C4 you
have to drop that yes you have to go
Bishop E2 but then Bishop B4 check
and here you cannot play in my G2
because computer suggested the best move
is King F1 once again so those are very
very complicated variation but let's say
what happens after Knight D2 and then
well a very unusual move but Queen E4
attacking everything and I think that
after
after Castle
there is Queen D5 and you're attacking
the mate and the Knight on D2
year complete collapse for sure on the
other hand I am so loath to play after
Queen E8 castles I think that this
position is just horrible horrible uh
Pawn down my opponent has the center
better development I I hate it so I'm
thinking that Nana has got to realize
she's got to play the chaotic move
captures on D5 because she can't allow
the alternative I'm with you 100 C4
Bishop E2 Bishop B4 Check Yes I'm I have
to compromise my king but after I play
the move King F1 I think I can fight
in this position better than maybe those
other positions I mean I still feel like
I've got some control yeah some chances
here right right whereas the other
position I think it's too easy for black
so I've got to make Black's life as
difficult as possible and I can I can
fight in this position I just wanted to
check
uh with the arena and just before we go
on break she did play night 8-4 by the
way and Bishop F5 okay this for me it's
such an easy move uh for those of you
who've watched our broadcast I must say
I'm so predictable I hate being pinned
it just it it just I feel this almost
physical uh restraint and you know let
let me out
so Queen B3 uh Arena prepares Knight C5
and we understand what herika was
thinking she she sees that Outpost and
she wants to fight for control of that
Outpost and so she eliminates the night
and after night uh F6 we're up to date
with the players this is true we have
minor peace and balance Bishop versus
knight right the pawn on G6 is just it's
we but there is a I mean I can't grab it
not yet not yet there's a double attack
uh Knight G4 and uh The Bishop's hanging
part on F2 so it's going to take some
care still I do like White's position
but it's not over over and we're gonna
it's very pleasant though definitely
we're gonna take a short break and we'll
see you on the other side of the break
see you soon in 2019 the Missouri
Bicentennial commission along with
Governor Mike Parson approved the
building of a life-size chess board to
celebrate the 200th anniversary of the
state of Missouri Dr Jeannie sinkfield a
lifelong patron of scouting in Great
Rivers Council board member proposed
that the project be built as an Eagle
Scout project Jeannie invited 16 year
old Andrew doughton of troop 6 Jefferson
City to take on this incredibly
important project
my name is Andrew Dowden and I belong to
troop 6 in Jefferson City Missouri so my
troop we were down camping down at the
sing fields and Jeannie came down and
asked you know is anyone close to
getting their eagle or needing a project
she had this idea of the Eagle Scout
project chessboard and she wanted
somebody to kind of work with her to see
what we could come up with at the time I
kind of had a project in line but when
she brought up this idea obviously I
wanted to choose it because it was a lot
better idea than what I had started
prior to this project I did not really
know anything about Chess once I got
into this project I downloaded an app on
my phone started playing chess and I
took the chest merit badge down at Scout
camp this was a bicentennial chessboard
for the Historical Society of Missouri
there were a lot of people that helped
me with this project because whenever I
I got the pictures from the Historical
Society to engrave onto the granite
I wasn't very familiar with the
technology needed to engrave on there so
I needed some assistance with that and
learning how to do it and after all that
I'm pretty sure I know how to do it now
so to engrave those Edge pieces I went
down to the Lake of the Ozarks Scout
Reservation and we used the epilogue
laser me and Thomas Yang did I wasn't
really expecting it to end out this big
but as we me and Jeannie were working
um it just got kind of got bigger and
bigger and bigger which I didn't have a
problem with I thought you know I can
take on a little bit more and a little
bit more and
it ended out to be a really really cool
project so we had a ribbon cutting of
the chess board and there were a whole
bunch of people there including the
governor the St Louis chess club the
World Chess Hall of Fame the State
Historical Society which all helped out
during this entire project
Jeannie was there I had to give a little
speech that I didn't really know I had
to do but that kind of has taught me a
little bit about speaking too so I think
that has helped me too this project it's
made me real proud that everyone is
enjoying it like every time I go down
there somebody's playing
um and then they're taking care of it
which really makes me proud because me
thinking all that time and everyone else
that's helped me sinking in all that
time like to see people use it but I
also like to see people appreciate it
[Music]
okay hi everyone so I often get this
mixed up and I will I always feel badly
when people mess up my name I call
Grandmaster Irina Crush Irina but I've
heard some people call her Irena so now
we're gonna get Irina or irina's answer
as to how she prefers to be cold yeah
well the answer to that Sabina is that I
like all the pronunciations of my name
in every language every accent it's all
good so in the US you definitely hear
Irina but the way you say it is very
nice and Irina or Irina it's all good
you know so um yeah you can keep doing
what you like Sabina all right well you
know how to calm down Irina I I will
keep calling you Rina and hopefully
you're rooting for her in this
tournament and others good luck to
everything and we'll see you guys soon
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
[Music]
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as high
profile tournaments that attract the
world's best players become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
meet me at the beauty the beauty in
Forest Park the muni's premier season
bursting with comedies romance and Magic
Begins June 12th with the muni premiere
of beautiful the Carole King musical
the Epic Summit continues with Disney's
Beauty and the Beast chess West Side
Story Little Shop of Horrors rent and
Sister Act
single tickets are now on sale at
muni.org
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program in the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grand Master
varuja nicobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between at-risk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since 2019. the St
Louis chess club has also created a
chess merit badge for the scouts BSA
quickly becoming one of the most popular
badges with more than 250 1000 Scouts
earning the badge since 2011. students
of chess can also pick up a copy of read
and write chess thanks to Club
co-founder Dr Jeannie Karen sinkfield
anyone can learn how to understand chess
notation in no time we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
[Music]
the muni's premier season bursting with
comedies romance and Magic Begins June
12th with the muni premiere of beautiful
the Carole King musical
the Epic summer continues with Disney's
Beauty and the Beast chess West Side
Story Little Shop of Horrors rent and
sister
[Music]
hello everyone this is wgm and former US
Women's Champion Sabina for sure I'm
very excited to be here in San Luis at
the Third Edition of the Karen's cup
I'll be taking over San Luis chess club
social media accounts so please if you
want to interact with me and see more
behind the scenes actions and videos of
the players be sure to follow Sandler's
chess club social media accounts
in Forest Park
it's your move the muni premiere of
Chess plays the muni through July 11th
sponsored by St Louis chess club and the
World Chess Hall of Fame for
ticketsmuni.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
[Music]
foreign
chess club is the Premier chess facility
in the United States and is among the
best in the world thanks to co-founders
Dr Jeannie Karen sinkfield and Rex
sinkfield the St Louis chess club is a
non-profit organization committed to
promoting the game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American Cup as
well as high profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Cairns cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over 2
000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
[Music]
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game landmarked by the
world's largest chess piece sitting
outside our front door the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy including various exhibitions
monthly concerts and much more whether
you are a beginner or a professional
there is something for everyone to learn
here at the World Chess Hall of Fame
enjoy free admission to our rotating
exhibitions and our Galleries and sign
up for chess events family friendly
programming and art classes and don't
forget to stop by our award-winning gift
shop Q Boutique and Shop a wide
selection of Chess related merchandise
for more information on current exhibits
please visit worldchess hof.org
[Music]
thank you
hello everyone and welcome back to round
seven we have one result in the history
books tonight we have a draw between
Abdul Malik and Mama data but the three
remaining games I have to say all look
very very
um well yeah promising and going for the
result uh most especially in the game
between Nana and Alexandra what um Nana
just got a bad position and uh is really
struggling as uh Alexandra is a pawn to
the good and the last move was Bishop E2
not not a move you want to play when
you're a pawn down your hope uh to be
able to Castle and
on a good day you utilize the e-files
she's not getting that opportunity if
black just takes on C4 I think her plan
is uh close your eyes and play Knight D6
Bishop takes D6 Bishop takes D6 and
again you know I'm hoping yes you can
take on F3 and everything's wrong I
agree everything's wrong but okay maybe
you know Rook C1 Rook takes C4 I'm not
anxious to take the Rook I'm just
keeping my Bishop on D6 I just don't
want a good piece why it has Bishops so
yeah you want to keep it as long as we
can leverage it into something wonderful
but I agree it's just bad material down
I'm just hoping that I'm not busted
actually that's that's the way I feel
about that Arena's position we left it I
really liked uh what she had done
against harika the last movement Rika
was Knight F6 well we Pawn on G6 we
can't capture it right away because
Knight G4 would
what would would be hurtful hurt my
feelings but Rook G1 on the other hand
this move really nice now when we crash
through with Rook takes G6 we're not
only winning a pawn but oh my goodness
we're doing it uh uh pinning our
opponents as well
we can take Bishop G6 sorry I think I
think you might want to use the Rook on
the H file so I'm assuming you want to
use the other Rook okay to G8 okay and
sorry you're about to say Bishop takes
G6 yes black still have Knight G4 well
and we're we're happy about them apples
that's an extra Pawn uh still work to do
but yeah it's a it's a solid extra pawn
and I don't you know in these positions
where your queen and uh
Knight you you immediately start
thinking should I be playing for F3 and
E4 but I I'd grab the pawn first first
and worry about more material later so
we like Arenas and then finally Bella
who's been on a roll
a roller coaster I should even say she
started with two losses she's had three
wins in a row she had the buy but she's
got a really good position and this is
the position where we left at King f8
now I'm warming up to what you said
originally which was maybe we should
just grab some space on the king side
with the move H5
I kind of like what Bella did but on the
other hand
we're we're gonna switch to Black Square
she's trying to dominate the black
squares yes uh G5 and H6 but from from
Elizabeth Elizabeth's point of view
she's trying to put up some kind of a
fearsome blockade Knight G7 maybe on a
good day this bishop will come to F5 a
couple of Trades and she will ease out
of her very cramped she's definitely
happy they got G6 H5 in indeed exactly
and if I'm in Dallas issues I'm thinking
how how can I open up the position
advantageously F4
where I was a if I were to play F4
if I don't get an F5 I'm a little bit
concerned so maybe I should be going F3
and G4 so for example let's suppose I go
Knight G5 this is a four instance
um and in my mind's eye I want to play
the moves F3 and G4 so I Elizabeth
played Knight A2 C7 okay
yes exactly
um I can take Knight G5 and then maybe
bring the other Knight to E6 okay very
good and I again uh
very consequentially you're threatening
my Pawn now here's where I uh I'm I'm
throwing caution to the wind if you will
I wanted to play the move G4 so in my
mind's eye you're supposed to take my
pawn and threaten a royal Fork I was
gonna take take and play F4 and I
thought I was going to get an F5 until I
saw the move Bishop H4 check and I
realize I'm barking up the wrong tree I
have to do
F4 and this is where
you know uh Elizabeth is like okay I've
got my blockade it might not be the
greatest blockade ever but uh at least
she's not losing the game uh what we
fear for her that she would be losing
the game so Bella's got to figure out
how to best
um arrange her pieces and by the way she
played the move Knight G3
anticipating that Knight G7
she she's anticipating Knight G7 and she
wants to stop the possibility of a
blockade on F5 was this the oh I see
O'Meara that you have the game of Nana
on your screen and uh we're thinking
Alexandra's got a great position uh the
uh the Oracle agree with this he does
and I was thinking that um if Alexandra
wins this game she has a chance first of
all to narrow the gap between her and
Anna zetonsky's the tournament leader so
they will only be half a point
apart and well she's very much in the
game
for the moment here I was trying to
consider the Alternatives because D
takes C4 is the strongest move in this
position Knight D6
Bishop takes D6 Bishop takes D6 I do
like Bishop F3 because it destroys
um
your structure completely and you will
still have to Castle short so here there
is a very nice move Queen E6 which
forces you to take on the Fate you don't
have the time to take on C5 so Bishop f8
King f8 I was thinking what if Queen did
too but it doesn't change anything in
the position because one of the most
important factors in this position is
this Square on D4 so Knight C6 then on
the the Knight is going to jump on D4 on
the next move so let's say if you Castle
after Knight D4
um White's position is
very difficult so I have troubles
finding a move here Bishop D1 or rookie
one but then if I essentially play yes I
I just have to tell you a mirror I find
this position repulsive
repulsive for why the structure the
Knight on D4 everything has gone wrong
it just and it's a terrible position I
have this nature with like a
really made things but I haven't
traveled to find one positive element in
this position I don't know what to
sublimate here for white exactly it's
just terrible everything is a disaster
from start to finish so but here let's
say Alexandra doesn't go for a d take C4
does she have an alternative so another
natural move in this position would be
D4 right
then why it still has 96 Bishop D6
Bishop D6 and of course I really like
GTX C4 because it opens the position so
much but here you have the usual Bishop
B3 GTX F3 and the same you can play
Knight C6 but then white has the
possibility of taking this phone I think
and you see the evaluation changes
dramatically here right because see I
don't think that you can play here
Knight D7 not what I want yes it's not
what you want and after Queen D4 white
is even much better so of course you
have to play Queen E6 here
force and white to take on the faith and
after king of Faith this position is
still much better for black but what I
don't like is that in this variation you
don't have the square on D4 which is
taken by black spawn so I think D takes
C4 do we have it on the board or not yes
sir what do we have on the board uh let
me just check for you uh sorry we we
have them a surprising move D7 D6 d D5
takes C4 that's a very very natural move
I I have a hard time understanding why
you wouldn't do that but I think from
Alexandra's point of view she's hoping
that she's got a queen coming to C6 for
example Knight takes she didn't want to
necessarily give up her dark squared
Bishop but she's looking at an
opportunity of trapping the night uh
evil intentions I would say is what
Alexandra has in mind but the move D7 D6
uh was a surprise move because D5 takes
C4 so natural just open the position and
use your Center D6 can I take with the
bishop exactly or what about the other
uh capture instead Bishop takes and here
I don't feel like for example if you
take I don't feel that uh
um you're getting that that terrible
position where the bishop was capturing
on F3 like here I have time maybe he
wants to play A6 after Bishop D6 is that
an option okay let's see a six oh
Knight C7
no I no no I'm good now I'm good now I'm
good
um Bishop takes D6 I I I'm thinking
Bishop takes D6 and well uh Alexandra's
lost a considerable part of her
Advantage suddenly well it's
it's shredded I think that after Bishop
D6 the position still looks oh and zero
complicated but yes but it went zero
zeros and well Bishop D6 and 96 96 is a
bit worse because after 96 if you play
let's say queen C6 but white still has a
few possibilities to to trade you know
like on B8 then on B7 then on D5 and
escape with a drop I see let's say
Knight B7 here maybe Rook B7 here I
don't know if um
C takes D5 should be included maybe now
the Knight is too active so may oh you
can still can take on C4 so maybe you
can play Queen C2 here so but Bishop D6
is more accurate here of course and I
don't think that black has anything
anymore here so let's say you will
develop your knight something like
Knight D6 or Knight C6 but after Knight
C6 this Pawn is hanging so and Knight C7
is a threat so you cannot do this then
Knight is six protecting the system
Square yes here but white can simply
Castle here
yeah and with that castling movement
without having to face consequences of
Bishop F3
whites right back in in business so yeah
the move d d six was just a big
inaccuracy a mistake it was a mistake uh
Alexandra allowed her opponent off the
hook D5 takes C4 was a really good uh
move I wanted to ask
um Bella played the move Knight G3 and
much to my surprise of Elizabeth played
King G7 I was betting dollars to Donuts
she was going to play Knight to G7 and
bring this Knight well if you or if you
prefer at night C7 to E8 to try to get a
light squared belt clade she put her
King in the way of the night King G7
Bella played Knight at G5 and this time
it's going to be hard to stop F4 F5 what
if I take on G5 for the night the night
yep and play H4
H4 so you kicked me good for you
uh why did I choose F1 in my mind's eye
my ideal square is F6 so I saw the
maneuver night H2 to G4 to F6 so I'll
try to stop at least a four or five idea
okay Bishop E6 and queen D7 Bishop E6 so
uh Knight f
and queen
to D7
okay
um I'm thinking about f2f3 so that
you'll be forced uh one day to oh your
cast one F3 well I'm thinking that my
Rook will be good on f file if I get to
play F3 and Knight you Knight G4 by the
way you're not using your Trump your
trumps are the queen side uh majority
I don't see C5 in the offing whereas I
do see white center and kingside
working so I I think uh Bella is
definitely for Choice I'm just a little
curious
um Elmira Almera if
if the engine thinks it's a big
Advantage I I really like White's
position but I'm wondering
what's the evaluation yes
that I have a line actually which I
analyzed after Knight G5 as you can see
the
um
but I really like uh the line that Nazi
proposal
so let's say if you take a
H take G5 H4 and if you play Knight F1 I
think that you should put your knight
immediately to E6 so you are attacking
the pawn on G5 okay there is no other
way for you to defend it than to play F4
and now you strike with C5 from the
center and as you can see black is
already slightly better wow so 96 is the
key move you want to develop your Bishop
but for the moment yes you can leave it
and see it boy that is a wake-up call
for me because I really thought that
Bella was in cruise control
and uh that makes all the difference too
slowly yeah things can turn around
exactly well it also means that Knight
takes Pawn takes H4 I'm gonna have to
keep an eye on the center and after
Knight to E2 if you do go in the same
way 96 F4 at least my knight is not on
F1 and I'm more or less defending the D4
Square so that C5 takes you don't have
as almero is about to show D4
but uh big advantages just kind of
melted away here in these last few moves
yeah yeah last time I think Irena is
still keeping her advantage
um she pushed the pawn to Asics
she she got around to so let's see how
did it go so after the move Knight F6
Rook to G1 Knight E4 by harika
pardon me uh A6 B6
and I'm assuming F3
right like there are some ideas maybe
even Bishop takes E4 might be working
now well I was looking very specifically
for Rook takes G6 and maybe uh on a good
day sure look take C6 so F2 F3 how would
the line go F2 Knight F2
C7
queen queen
exactly and uh
a pile up right just uh Rook to see what
really bad yeah uh can I avoid it I
don't know designate G3 of trap three it
must be it must be because uh the
Alternatives look really Grim I want to
say so Knight G3 uh E4 uh
uh eyeballing E5
yeah
yeah this position after Knight G3
because I also tried this very human
defense I think that black is losing
after Knight C5
well and I'm threatening it might be
seven yes so Knight takes upon let's
let's have a look and now because your
queen is Tethered to the night um
and uh you would have to protect the
Knight on G3 as well so it doesn't work
at all and after twin is overworked yes
yes Knight F2 I think that you can play
Rook G6
so Queen is seven yeah probably yes very
natural so that's why Irene I think
concluded the movie six here so let's
say now The Rook is hanging we should
play something look
D G1 and after Queen A3 the computer
suggests a very nice Queen B4 move so he
just simply leaves the bishop on D3 but
I don't think this is a variation very
easy to spot you know because I mean
before is essential here with the idea
of playing Queen D6 and queen C6 and
cream is let's say if you take of course
Mrs mate
so if she goes for this line she really
needs to calculate it precisely
but if not Rook G6 then Knight F2 can
actually work because then maybe Rook C1
I know and I can take on D3 Queen D3 and
White's advantages not that big here
well sorry I have one question
and for arena now keep in mind the round
two game with humpy has been
disqualified because don't be withdrew
Arena started great she almost started
3-0 by the way because the game with
Hopi she was better she started with a
plus two score but it's been a slide so
now it's 50 but you can say still
finished strong as today's game looks
looks like he's going
now remember I'm a pond grubber so the
move Knight E4 I I see that Knight F2
tactically could maybe work for black
suppose I just on his own A6 by the way
that include A6 yeah I apologize A6 B6
let me let me get rid of this guy and
let me just come back and I'm eyeballing
Queen F7 as my follow-up and with the
queen on F7 I'm always dreaming I have
and you might pick up E4 engine six
months
on the way to the Checkmate wow I mean
uh normally I'm happy with a pawn but
you said two in a check maybe boy uh
that's that that would be very very nice
so if I just take on e4 play it I want
to say calmly just calm down slow it
down by the way Knight C3 now I'm really
warming up to Bishop takes E4 because I
have Rook G4 and any Knight F6 is allow
Rook G6
uh why isn't this just very good for a
real like very good it's gonna be my
question for Almira does Irina have
something better than F3
I really like this move Bishop before I
think it has a very strong positional
decision yeah so Bishop B4 D takes C4
followed by Knight C3 uh what can you do
here maybe you have to protect the bone
on or four yes Rook H E8 and then
um
Queen F7 is also very attractive move
between F7 I was thinking maybe the Laos
Rook f8 then
of course computer thinks that a white
is still winning but then after Queen G6
so Queen G6 Rook G6
Rook F2 Knight E4 you know maybe
there is some way you know to continue
the struggle so you will attack the
bound on uh like if you can maybe play
Rook F3 rookette 2 but the opponent C6
is also hanging here so it's um it can
be a very nice end game for white as
well so after he takes C4 Knights is not
not Queen F7 Knight C3 Rook h8 let's say
what if we try a very human move Rook G4
that is nice there is one weakness in
White's position is the Pawn on F2 so
black has to do something in order to
create a well counter yes some counter
player cannot even call this a counter
play so Queen F6 and here like Queen C2
was the move that I was looking at and
they think that then you can double your
Rooks on the G file and it will be fine
looks terrific for arena and she did
take on e4 she just made that move like
that decision very much and we have some
questions from social media as
we invite our our audience to join the
conversation this one is from Will on
Twitter
what is your most memorable blunder oh
boy uh you got you got it yeah exactly
you got a week
um ladies first
um I think the most memorable one is the
quickest blender I ever made which was
Blended on the third move on the third
move yeah it's hard to manage but I did
it what did you damage it was Carol can
and I blundered upon it was if you you
can pull up on if we can sure outward
I'll just put it on the board I'll I'll
start to teach everyone how not to play
Caracas okay this is the most memorable
Nazis was memorable not before 93 Knight
C3 D5 yeah and queen E2
I've never seen this move before right
this game and I thought well I didn't
understand the idea so instead of making
a normal move like E6 I played G6 and
that blunders the pawn on D5 and this is
what your opponent Glee fully showed you
and I was playing on stage Against The
Grandmaster and this was very
embarrassing yes how awkward
um over to you Almera your most
memorable blunder well I have so many of
them and I think that where we are
designed in a way that we should forget
about them I think that otherwise we
will never be able to play chess for
such a long time and have such a long
career but I think most of them happen
when I I cannot
cope with the pressure and then my hands
shake you know my mind disconnects and
well terrible blunders happened I
remember it I just threatened my
opponent with a mating one and she
simply gave her Rook you know which I
could have taken and I was so
manipulated with this meeting ideas that
they didn't take like I had the queen on
F6 she played rook h8 and I could have
taken like Queen of six takes h8 there
was absolutely no other pieces on the
board but I well and I managed to lose
this game as well so oh I want to forget
those actually yeah uh very hard to
forget some of my uh blunders but my
most memorable blender for sure was two
games left in the intrazoneal it was a
qualifying event for the candidates
tournament and with two draw simple
draws I would qualify for the candidates
and this was a very very big deal to get
to the candidates and my penultimate
round opponent was Victor korchnine and
Victor
uh was also fighting for the candidates
we both eventually qualified but the
bottom line was in our particular game I
saw a draw I saw a draw but I had
offered Victor a draw
earlier in the game and he had denied
yeah but in in a way that kind of like
hurt me like not completely yeah like no
no no no no draw so I wanted to punish
him so I saw the draw
which would qualify me for the
candidates and instead I went for what I
thought was a winning variation with a
massive massive hole which he spotted
and he won the game and it was sort of
like ah what's the take away from that
kill yourself I don't know what the
thing I mean it's just it's just this
horrible I mean you know the howler the
howler uh lucky for me I did win the
last game and a must-win situation I did
qualify for the candidates but that was
you know really really you know like
super hurtful because I thought I had
ruined
my chances for a very very much that's
what I hate about blunders there's no
lesson to learn from it yeah because
you're always going to plunder right but
in your case though Mary you kind of
intimated that you you understood that
you know as the stakes are you get get
higher you know the more pressure you're
under you you kind of feel that uh what
you can do maybe to train yourself like
uh if Anna zatonski who is always into
time trouble with she was to blunder in
the time trouble as her coach was I'd
say okay let's work on your time trouble
let's get you we're going to play
training games where you only have five
minutes and I have 15 right and we'll
see how you like it and then we're going
to play some training games where you
have 15 and I have five and then we'll
see how you like it and maybe you'll
start to play uh faster but uh here's
our our choices I switched I I went from
Costa nuke to crush because but yes
yesterday when they were playing each
other they started to regret your right
right
defeated uh Arena Crush
but we still all have well we're not
allowed to pick Anna because she was
already
fighting for a second place that was the
idea and let's jump again to a social
media question thank you very much for
the question by the way will thanks for
reminding us about it right we just love
those blunder questions
this one I'm going to need help on who's
it from from
Twitter how come GMS play the benoni but
each time I analyze it with the engine
it shows plus one for one well exactly
uh the the engine is Prejudice in terms
of those openings where white has a big
control of the sander so if you play The
King's Indian for example the engine is
really going to say hey White's much
better why go into a position where
you're you're you're minus one and the
answer to that question is that both the
benoni and King's Indian are very very
rich
defenses in terms of counter-attacking
opportunities so a lot of Grandmasters
play in open tournaments where they have
to score 80 85 90 to get a top prize you
can't just play Queen's Gambit declines
and uh Berlin's uh you'll draw your way
out of the tournament so sometimes you
have to take risks and yes the benoni is
a risky opening but sometimes you win a
lot of games too but do you agree Oscar
that it's actually a plus one
[Music]
yeah I do think it's it's it's a good
Advantage actually this way the benoni
and the King's Indian myself so I've
suffered a lot but you're absolutely
right yes sir those are the openings
that offer uh so many counter chances
you know the player with the black
pieces but actually I was still
contemplating the question on the
blunders and I think what could be the
moral of the story is that in some way I
think the chess players do not accept
that they can actually make mistakes
because the mistakes can be absolutely
fatal so I think one of the
um conclusions uh for me over the years
was that maybe we should be kinder to
ourselves and accept that mistakes do
happen so blunders do happen and well
life goes on and the next game could be
be a masterpiece for sure I just won
other nice little issue there with the
with the question from our viewer and
that was that Victor corchinoy really
liked to work with Junior players uh he
liked
to share his knowledge but he also liked
the passion of working with Juniors and
he worked with one uh beside myself many
other Juniors he worked with and one was
yurun Pickett and your room Paquette was
a top top Junior from Holland and had
become a 2700 player so he had reached
the top ten
in your your Rune love to play The
King's Indian full stop and end of story
love the king's Indian whereas Victor
loved to bash the king's Indian light
you can't play it it's a terrible
terrible and the joke was was that yurun
stopped playing chess because coach nor
convinced him that the king's Indian was
unplayable and if you can't play the
Kings in here yeah what's the point of
Chess Justice wasn't any more fun it was
that loyal exactly
exactly and we do have a knight C3
harika did not respect to your story uh
did korchner ever play Kasparov in the
king's Indian oh yes and oh yes and I
remember this very very very vividly it
was Barcelona the GMA World Cup I was
having breakfast with Victor which is
kind of rare because I wasn't the early
riser but for some reason I was having
breakfast and Victor had this
unbelievable like ridiculously
unbelievable idea of how to crush the
king's Indian and he was going to play
a2a4 in a very specific line of the
king's Indian and he says I will crush
him the coach now I will crush Kasparov
and send him home you know like with a
tail between his legs kind of thing and
I was like dang if A4 works the king's
Indian's really unplayable so he got the
very position that he had been preparing
and Gary over the board refuted his
preparation and Gary Juan a really
impressive game and we were all like
congratulations he kept the king's
Indian defense yes yes yes yes yes
precisely so he kept the kings in the
defense alive and uh that was we had a
marvelous game
then we had some
a younger generation very strong players
like Hikaru Nakamura and rajapov
continue to play king's India exactly
exactly and keep it alive uh and uh
Hikaru I remember one of really really
nice game at uh here in the St Louis
chess club and Scholastic Center against
Wesley so that was like a a spectacular
game in fact but I have seen the king's
Indian get crushed just like you know
like snuffed out you never had a chance
but when black wins the games they tend
to be spectacular yes because they
always end in a Checkmate exactly there
was also one game Gary kasparo versus
you ruin your room Paquette
who was playing Black in that case yeah
it was Gary kasbara playing black and
the winning move was night on G black
winning move was night on G3 to H1 oh
wow I know it was really uh really
spectacular look it up yeah
Rook G4 and the more I'm looking at this
the more I'm liking White's position I
mean was there not to like roof G1 E4
everything seems bad for her Quinn up
seven
in in the pocket as well Queen F7 and
just a moment ago by the way I think we
were looking
Almera was showing us Rook E8 Queen F7
f8 yeah and I didn't understand one move
here I was thinking Rook takes G6 so the
idea was well I can maybe mess up your
opponents a little bit go Queen A3 check
oh how about that that's a double
earphones but it's you're losing time
right and probably a pawn or two or two
but A3 A6 are not the greatest pawns
true that it's still though it looks it
looks good it looks good so Arena's
doing well how is Nana doing against
Alexandra we thought the move uh D6
allows her back in the game and Almera
back over to you uh after Bishop D6
Queen d8 Bishop G3 and a whole new
kettle of fish is on the board
I understand what is happening in this
game you stop understanding chats
certainly right well I'm trying to
understand Black's idea now so uh she
takes she Alexander just played 96 in
White in white uh to take on D5 which is
a very simple move so Nana just made it
on the board so let's see Knight D5 yeah
and white can simply Castle White has a
slightly better Pawn structure here yes
those two isolated powers and here
um well the Knight on D5 of course is
very active and what Alexandra probably
wanted to achieve is still to keep the
square D4 available for her Knight and
at some point maybe to play Bishop F6 so
maybe she after 95 she should try
and play A6 because I'm trying to
justify a black strategy here right so
if Knight CS3 now you maybe you can take
on C3 but then it will take away the
square D4 from uh from your night so can
you play Knight D4 here I'm not even
sure so 94
she takes D4 Queen D4 then Bishop F6 and
then probably you will take on C3 and
equalize okay now I understand of course
probably this is the variation that
Alexandra calculated so she will not
take on C3 but she will play Knight D4
here but what if Knight goes to A3 and
transfers it to C4 so much more
positional idea yeah yes and I like this
idea very much so here black would have
to come up with something else because
after Bishop F6 then the Knight goes to
C4 protecting the pawn on B2 and white
is much better here yeah no I love that
the C5 Pawn is a serious long-term
weakness I would totally agree and I
love the positional approach of Knight
A3 to C4 very much uh turning our
attention to the game of uh Bella versus
a very interesting development truly uh
Elizabeth so uh Bella did like my move
uh Knight F4 F1 and again I was thinking
that on a good day I'm looking to
transfer the Knight to G4
um there was a there was a drawback the
drawback was 96 F4 and suddenly the
Counter-Strike in this enter with C5 and
white wasn't ready to meet this
Counter-Strike as C5
um
Elizabeth probably feeling like
ourselves that she's the one under
pressure did not want to play C5
Lawrence he just wanted to complete her
development not to counter-attack Bishop
F2 gift me the pawn and Bella's looking
to put her Knight on E3 we do have to
move G3 pardon me H3 G3 and it's like
one of those I I I love suckering my
opponent into you know coming up the
board and this Pawn is this opponent H3
now has become a strong pass Pawn
instead of
and that's why chess is such a fantastic
game what for you is a strong pass Pawn
is for me a weak liability uh something
I will uh gleefully collect uh when I
can uh why is it a strong I guess we'll
see who is right exactly it's a
Marketplace and uh what are my dips
what do you think Amira I say that H3
ponds a week a week and a liability and
the engine says no it's a a powerful
asset well I told you yes sir that your
days were numbered
like it's better here actually and age
three is a trump is it Trump yes I think
so because I think that Bella played way
too slow she gave Elizabeth the
possibility to reorganize her pieces now
her King is quite safe but let's see
after this move B6 the computer actually
thinks that white is better because
H2 and maybe Knight F3 support the pawn
on D4 so maybe it's not so B6 was slow
what should she have played to keep her
Advantage well actually I don't think
it's the matter of being slow or more
active I think that the computer likes
this move and it's very yes it's very
systematic in those types of position
because once you
um stabilized at this flank then you
play a four and uh well you stabilize
the the queen side and then you have a
lot more squares here so you play one
move here one move there so because this
switch two let's say B6 actually
weakness uh the weakens they see six
pounds and I don't like it that much so
let's say Knight H2 here right and here
okay now I struggle to understand
because his strategy here is to play B5
and probably immediate before with Rook
B8 wow still ah yes that's the idea okay
now because of B6 and not not B6 not B5
you have this Rook A6 and you protect
the pound so you are not losing it
that's the huge difference let's say
well if you play B6 and I attack your
Pawn then you don't have Rook A6 while
after A4
oh sorry like A4 here so Knight H2 B5 if
I play Queen C2 you can still protect
the pawn by Rook A6
and then be Force coming Rook B8 and I
open all the files now yes I clearly
understand why black is better but let's
have a look after B6 what does that
change
on the board why Elizabeth played B6
because she wants to place aside here
and not be five before so let's try
C5 here and maybe while you have the
possibility you still can Castle here
that's not a pawn that's hanging on C5 I
I couldn't capture the the pawn you
could but I think it could be rather
dangerous here so let's say one of The
Wishes wow you still
didn't castle and then
as as president of the pond grubbers
Association I have to explain to my
members why I didn't capture the pawn
and okay because he opened the B file
you say you Castle here yes maybe Rook
B3 so um I want to double my Rooks on
the B file the position is open and I'm
a bit afraid because your knight is
stuck for the moment on H2 the G3 is
hanging here exactly I have to play Move
Like Rook C3 and rook h8 and you're
getting a very nice compensation yes but
if I take one C3 can you actually take
with the queen
It's like because D4 now right I opened
this long diagonal so Queen D2 with that
open diagonal Pawn on H3 just became 10
times stronger
true uh true that uh and this is
actually not an extra pound because you
have a double G phone exactly exactly so
we do have in the position uh Knight H2
B6 and uh
okay you wanted after the move C5 to
Simply castle and not capture the pawn
and that strikes me as a very decent
move as well how would the game unfold
in this case
well it's not so easy let's say here you
I would feel that now that you've played
C5 uh from if I offer a human
perspective you need to put something on
d8 exactly so but then maybe you can
take on C5 so if you don't play so which
Rook on Z8
it's not so easy yeah yes I'm not sure
and you don't want to play my day six
because you just played Knight C7 right
another idea would be to play C4 B5 B4
but so what's fascinating to me is how
many times you switched your strategies
exactly from one moment you were playing
A4 B5 B4 the next moment you're playing
C5 sacrificing a pawn and then playing
C4 so uh really uh hard to keep track of
what's going on by the way let's just
drop in on Arena's game because Arena
might be just really just simply it's a
very nice in-game Advantage Queens are
off the board and
black has two weak pawns exactly oops
sorry I wasn't blue when we left it we
just left it with the move Knight C3
rookie eight Rook G4 and we were saying
okay harika what are you going to do
white is building up intense pressure on
the E4 as well as G6 Pawn I'm gonna play
Rook G1 maybe even on a good day Queen
F7 well Eureka said I see the queen F7
dropping in I don't want to deal with
that let's trade the Queens
Rook to G1 picking up a Tempo against
and here Arena can just pick off the
bond right what do you take with the
Rooker the Knight
both are so tall both are good right I
mean both are so tempting uh normally
speaking when you are attacking you
don't want to unnecessarily trade off
attacking pieces I would think that this
Rook is better than this rook and this
Rook is better than this see two
defensive Rooks on the other hand I love
the Knight on e4 and the fact that
you're not uh no longer attacking the
Knight that was why I was thinking I
would take with the Rook I think both
are good I like 94 because like you
mentioned I think my trade my Rook is
better and I want to play Rook F4 and
use that Rook on the open file maybe
yeah yeah no this looks really really
strong uh are the clocks a factor
um harika has six thin minutes and Irina
also has about 17 minutes pretty even
for 33 moves no I don't think uh
time is a factor as we take a break for
around
7 with time control coming up we'll see
on the other side of the break see you
soon
[Music]
watch Hessler has mostly influenced your
chess career and why this is very
difficult question I am saying many
times I don't have just one role model I
admire people for different skills and
this is definitely all the world
champions and especially like I'm a
mother have two kids and some chess
players women who combine just their
chess career and still playing like
competitive chess this is uh Pierre
kramlin who is still very strong in her
age and Monica sojko who had like three
kids and managing like her chess career
and another is
who became a GM in very like late age
like for around 40 I think she became a
GM
um you know I studied games from a lot
of good players and I definitely did
spend time on games collections you know
from the world champions and I feel like
probably probably someone like botvanic
in his Games Collection and you know
just learning a lot of Concepts from him
um opening things you know strategic
things I would say probably probably him
it's where I got my appreciation for big
Center and Bishop hair when I was in
little kid
um
starting from aliochine I think to
casparov for car park no kramnik and
then all of them
during this time they were very popular
I think it was Anatoly karpov I really
like to check his games with my watch
when I was young so probably yeah
probably it's just cup I'm a big fan of
financial carpool and also Judith polka
so from my anger days I used to follow
their games and
their play has inspired me a lot
for Blanca and halogen was a ones that I
really loved their games and their style
casually was looking their games to
learn how to play chess and so and I
would call their names I think lab milk
kramnik or during my childhood days I
used to see a lot of his games and I
think somewhere I really like his style
and maybe not game wise but Judith
Polgar has a lot of influence on me as a
women player to be doing well and the
men to beat the strong man and like to
be there so definitely these two I think
are have influenced me a lot I was a fan
of Bobby pictures games when I was young
uh also Michael Tau was my favorite
chess player so I guess they influenced
my
style of play well honestly speaking my
dad is a grand master and he used to be
professional like when I was very young
so he had the deepest impact on me from
everybody because he taught me and my
brother at the early age how to play and
of course he went with us to tournaments
and he had been my teacher up till 16
before I actually met other trainers I
wish I wish I had such a player you know
it's such an influencer Mentor in a way
because
when I was growing up I wasn't really
excited about Chess lines and like moves
and champions in a way I was excited
about the psychological part of a battle
and I was I liked
um to read chess books I mean from Jazz
Champions but not about chess moves or
openings or middle games nothing about
that but rather about psychological
preparation and about how games like uh
went and how they prepared and what went
wrong if they lost so I didn't have a
chess Mentor in a way and I feel that
I'm lacking this like information right
now because definitely like your
youngest years are the best in order to
consume and um
be able to learn certain material but of
course it's never too late with the chat
book and what I'm trying to do right now
is to learn from those great chess
Champions and their games because well
you need to know history in order not to
make the same mistake in your own games
[Music]
the muni's premier season bursting with
comedies romance and Magic Begins June
12th with the muni premiere of beautiful
the Carole King musical
the Epic summer continues with Disney's
Beauty and the Beast chess West Side
Story Little Shop of Horrors rent and
sister
[Music]
hello everyone this is wgm a former US
Women's Champion Sabina fosher I'm very
excited to be here in San Luis at the
Third Edition of the Karen's cup I'll be
taking over San Luis chess club social
media accounts so please if you want to
interact with me and see more behind the
scenes actions and videos of the players
be sure to follow San Luis chess club's
social media accounts
[Music]
thank you
hi everyone I'm here with International
Master gunai Mama Zada who just won her
game hi gunai
thank you for joining me for a short
interview congratulations first of all I
know you got a little bit lucky today
uh with a win how do you feel it's the
first round is always nice to win
um I mean there's not much things to say
because she just pondered in the opening
uh I don't know why I suppose she
doesn't play Marathi so we transpose it
from the Knight of three Knight F6 to
that position
so I suppose just she wasn't really
aware of the opening and there she had
to play Bishop D7 and the queen D2 and
Knight G4 so it would be her accurate
idea but yeah the way you should play it
is just wonder yeah she probably missed
96 1966 or Bishop takes eight one of
those uh probably still jet like how do
you feel yourself I know you you came
the day before so you had maybe a day to
come back how do you feel with the time
different time
because I was expecting that I would be
accommodating earlier so I was kind of
sleepy today but it's nice that I
finished with the winning and so I can
have a rest more okay I won't keep you
much thanks so much for stopping by good
luck in the future rounds and uh
hopefully you get some rest and ready
for a future video games thank you
the beauty in Forest Park
it's your move the muni premiere of
Chess plays the muni through July 11th
sponsored by St Louis chess club and the
World Chess Hall of Fame for
ticketsmuni.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
[Music]
foreign the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr Jeannie
Karen sinkfield and Rex sinkfield the St
Louis chess club is a non-profit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
posting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American Cup as
well as high profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Cairns cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over
2000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
[Music]
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess is
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game landmarked by the
world's largest chess piece sitting
outside our front door the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy including various exhibitions
monthly concerts and much more whether
you are a beginner or a professional
there is something for everyone to learn
here at the World Chess Hall of Fame
enjoy free admission to our rotating
exhibitions in our Galleries and sign up
for chess events family friendly
programming and art classes and don't
forget to stop by our award-winning gift
shop Q Boutique and Shop a wide
selection of Chess related merchandise
for more information on current exhibits
please visit worldchess hof.org
[Music]
Forest Park the muni's premier season
bursting with comedies romance and Magic
Begins June 12th with the muni premiere
of beautiful the Carole King musical
the Epic summer continues with Disney's
Beauty and the Beast chess West Side
Story Little Shop of Horrors rent and
sister
[Music]
welcome back everybody so far we have
one result today it was a drop between
Abdul Malik and Mama Zara but in the
three remaining games boy we're seeing
good advantages uh to White buyers white
has Advantage across the board and Bella
especially her last move I really really
like Queen C2 we had one game where
Advantage one from black to white that
was the Alexandra game and what a
turnaround that game has been because
Nana was in trouble right out of the
opening but her last move Knight C6 is
bringing her in my opinion a very
serious Advantage I don't know uh Almera
but it sure feels like
like uh Alexandra has blown it and she
has only two minutes left yes sir yes I
think this is probably the most
important factor now for how many moves
well this is the move 25 wow 20 years so
they still have 15 move to make
so the move Knight C6 the the power
behind that move is very clear attacks
the queen on uh D4 attacks the bishop on
E7 forces the queen to back up and to
defend the bishop but the problem as I
see it is the move Rook D1
uh prevents you from playing Rook d8
there's no Rook d8 anymore and I'm
threatening to play the move Rook takes
D3 at Knight D4 I think I think I have
to get rid of your knight on C6 exactly
and she's done
most of the pawn exactly and uh here I
pause for a moment because the move I
really want to play is Knight takes E7
Queen takes E7 Queen takes D3 I I think
I'm winning a very nice uh extra pawn
and maybe more
uh well you you're probably gonna have
to go into a major because you don't
want to face a consequence of the bishop
to DC so if we back up just to move
white has to decide here which end game
they want to go to precisely Bishop
versus Bishop right Knight versus bishop
or just Queen and Rook exactly because
just as you described it we do have
alternative choices Queen takes D3 and
this is with Bishops or with major
pieces and there's where your judgment
and uh well just your experience comes
in handy by the way Knight D4 on the
board because
Alexandra's Knight is in danger of just
simply getting trapped uh Rook takes D3
Knight takes E7 on tap for Nana Knight
D4 on the board
um and
and what's going on in the game between
Bella who's been on the street right we
talked about uh the streak of Fabiano
seven in a row well she's been putting
together a 3-0 streak and what is
happening here look at this Pawns the
pawn structure is so difficult to
evaluate what is this all white pawns
are on the black squares and Bella has
the black squared Bishop right so that
should be bad yes but I think it's good
okay
um now I would agree that pawn on H3 is
a weakness
without the white square Bishop it's a
weakness okay the training is weak
working
um but it's concrete right because the
last move C5 black is ready to play
Knight E6 and presumably uh
fix a lot of her problems so are we
taking the pump
what do you think are we grabbing
why not
takes I suppose right Rook takes
night
[Music]
eight or B8 well if you drop back this
is what I was thinking is I'm trying to
win somebody back
the night on E6 by the way is making
very powerful impression on me is
actually if you do get managed to get
rid of the G3 Pawn then I could it's not
that I know white could do instead of
winning the C5 Pawn please that's when
the H3 pawn and F5 Pawn Knight F3 go
into Knight H4 like it I like it very
very much so Knight H3 Knight to D4
H4 unless
well I mean desperate times call for
desperate measures the problem is when
you take the pawn on F5 you don't just
win the pawn on F5 it just feels like my
position collapses
you do it with check and you hit the
bishop so okay
um you know close your eyes
and just see what this position might
bring you King D2 King D2 and I think
once I kick your night out with Bishop
E3 or G3 yeah go ahead and tell me which
which way you're going to kick me out
because I might I might invite myself to
uh and by the way 36 seconds and Ticking
for 36 oh no Bella has eight minutes oh
eight minutes sorry I thought that was a
zero on the left apologies but Elizabeth
has two and a half minutes gotcha she's
apologies and they also have about 12
moves to go I
if Bella finds this idea Knight f39h4 I
think she can
increase her advantage and then
Elizabeth in time trouble will have to
make that decision sacrifice The
Exchange well again I just don't I don't
see much of a choice Knight F3 Knight E6
Knight H4 like you said not only are you
winning this Pawn on F3 but you might be
winning the pawn on H3 as well that's
why it's got to go should white have
been more patient instead of Knight H4
let's make
King D2 or some move that prepares me
for I understand what you mean so let's
say King D2 let's say I play C4 so again
I'm I'm inviting you to Bishop E3 Ah
that's yet another Preparatory move
gotcha but because if I don't have to
rush I would rather not like give you
any counter play
that's
nothing this is interesting
even after I play night age for here and
you take my Bishop is like a big Pawn
but it's a big Rook
so okay so let's be really gross about
it if we will we'll we'll do some kind
of crazy crazed Fortress or variation
Magnus famously said I don't believe in
fortresses here what I'm trying to say
and what you stated is the bishop is a
big Pawn Yeah it's not really it doesn't
feel like a big Bishop
and it's
I desperately need a white square bishop
or a night uh
but let's jump to the game of arena for
a moment because she's a she was a
well I was about to say she was a
partner but somehow the A6 Pawn that
wait a minute Rook A1 yeah sure
Wednesday seven
because it can't be seven there is what
96. let's see how we just got here okay
so she won the pawn and uh there goes
harika trying to win a pawn back but
she's invited Rook A1
and after rookie won
if King B7 96 96 yeah she's played Rook
A1 so King B7 Shaq
King here you can just play Rook F6
oh you like Rook F6 because on Knight F7
maybe it still continues
95 Rook H5 I was gonna take oh okay that
works well King B7
sneaky
wow
and
yeah sorry King B7 didn't mean America
played G5 not King B7 so Rook A1 G5
oops sorry
Rook A1
G5
okay let me just pause for a second
oh yes um Erica wants to go King B7 and
not allow 96. right this well just a
second so first of all I like what you
said free Pawn you had me at freeform
uh uh Knight F7
so I'm kind of trying to uh trick you
here do I have Knight takes nope I don't
night takes B4 yeah not enough a knight
D6 check right Knight D3 for checks
sorry
timer Factor here
um not really Irina has five and a half
minutes harika 11 minutes and they are
only three moves away
besides G5 uh pardon me besides Knight
takes G5
just
I mean 95 and Knight F7 looks like
you're winning a piece
well maybe not a piece but
it's good enough though you're saying
just Knight takes G5 and Knight F7 is
good enough and uh Arena feels the same
way Knight takes
and she's looking at this Knight F7
she's looking at crashing down can I
play Knight takes B4 no
I can't because
anytime if I put my king either d8 well
d8 I walk into Rook f8 but that's bad
news but uh D6 I'm walking into Knight
F7 check aren't I yes and that's
Dreadful simply Dreadful
okay so I don't have night before for
her Rica
Knight takes G5
uh we're not seeing it uh amera we think
arena is winning this game what game
caught your eye I was actually analyzing
the um the position between bellacut in
Australia and Elizabeth pets it was a
commentive mistakes I think today is a
very strange round but let's say
um Bella decided to take on C5
so here in this position no Knight F3
Elizabeth instead of taking with the
pound on C5 and force and Bella to take
because now Bella actually is not forced
to take maybe she can have another move
but okay she played
after Bishop C5 I think she can play
Knight F3 you have this wonderful D4
Square Castle but then Bella two
classified with xc5 Rook C5 Knight F6
Knight E6 so and Bella didn't take on D5
she played Rook C2 I was thinking Rook
C8
Rook Z Rook seed here let's say King D2
because you need to
yes on C2 Square so Rook B8
actually just a very interesting
variation because
this is very
natural so but after Rook B3 Knight F1
Knight C5 black is actually winning
wow so you're one on H3 is a great asset
so you you should make of course a very
different move after Rook B8 I was
thinking about King situ but then what
if Knight D4 check right yes so if
you're going on D3 then I will go night
night E6 and it will be a Perpetual or
repetition right but then after Knight
D4 what if
King B1 and as you can see after Rook B3
black is winning once again so I think
that they are heading for
repetition yes repetition well for
Elizabeth that will be a tremendous save
because we thought that out of the
opening she stood really really badly
and she fought her way back to a draw
that would be and it will be Bella's
very first draw of the tournament too by
the way and the variation you're showing
is very
um consequent uh you look to C8
you don't want to see The Rook landing
on C1 so any so trades Rook takes C8
Rook takes C8 you don't want to see the
land of Rook landing on C2 so you defend
the square and
well you've gotta am I supposed to be
careful exactly because I feel at night
and we'll come in then three pointers
just win it precisely precisely so and
two minutes for Elizabeth yes and five
minutes for Bella okay so but a draw
would be a great result I I really
thought that Bella uh was going to uh
take this game and what what's happening
uh between Nana and um and they went
into the major peace end game right
Brooks and she did go uh capturing the
uh night a quick pause here for just a
second how would you recapture I
me too
it's rarely the right take yes but I
think this might be one of those one of
those very rare occasions because in my
view
there's a possibility of a queen in
ponenge there's a small pasta so taking
with the F Pawn playing H3 in King H2
getting that cocoon is very nice she
took with the HG uh nothing wrong with
that and we're quickly caught up with
the players we've been seeing uh some
rook and pawn end games and
um major peace endings uh with this I
want to say extra big Pawn uh how do how
would you evaluate this would you say 90
60 I have a little bit of bias here yes
I had this game against Valentina gunina
who won the first care in scrap in 2019.
with the remarkable I was down three
ponds in Queen and Rook end game and I
won you were down three points yes so I
believe Queen and Rook can create a lot
of counter play okay because her King
was a little bit weak so I found a way
to
when I was not expecting to win of
course but and since then anytime I get
Queen and rooken game whether I'm upon
or down upon I cannot
relaxation the game is still for three
results cruising to Victory Amira jump
in with the engines assessment of this
extra Pawn for Nana this ending I like
White's extra Pawn but is it
A A major advantage
um quite because I think that the
computer is evaluate this position is
technically winning but uh yes Nazi
shared her personal experience and I
really think that this
um there is a possibility for black to
create some counter play and well
different positions but here you want to
bring the Rook on age six but
unfortunately all the files are open so
here white has a very healthy postpone
so your best way would be to to block it
of course I don't know if you should try
and play Queen B5 immediately or to put
the Rook on B8 but let's say if you play
Queen B5 then maybe you should take one
take on E8 Rook takes E8
and well this will be actually easier to
defend yes or don't you think with one
Rook because now you have all these
possibilities which are
um
with the possible mating threads I think
that's the key in this major piece end
game that it's not easily winning
because any Rook end game is a draw
right
and how do we make progress without
offering any exchanges that's the
problem uh by the way we did see h7h6
which to my eyes is a very human move I
mean you want to just make lift I agree
you're giving up any ideas of
checkmating down the H file but h7h6
very quickly Rook takes E8 Rook takes EA
Queen to D3 again it's about uh
advancing this Pawn as far as you can
one question so I really want to play
Queen E2 okay but then my ideal Rook end
game is if my Rook is behind your Pawn
precisely but of course white will play
Rook B1 to stop you now is this still a
draw no I would say that this is winning
winning for white uh because they can't
get there fast enough maybe King f8
right are you in the Square nope I'm not
in the triangle and then triangle I'm
not no you're not you will unfortunately
for black after Rook B1 you probably
have to withdraw your Rook blockade it
and uh well you might end up in a game
like uh alkyne capablanca from their
world championship match with the Rook
uh behind uh White went on to win so the
desirable Queen E2 you need to do it in
a better way
um
makes me ask if you want to put your
Rook behind the pond
repeat one
why aren't you telling me about I don't
know uh counter Spiel B5 I think I can
easily defend because it's just the F2
Pawn right
well just a second is that just is 23
here still good enough for candy should
be right
um
I wouldn't be so dismissive
too uh one all I can suggest is that
when you're defending these end games
upon down
play actively
play actively uh usually when you when
you defend them passively then you're
giving your opponent everything that
they want and in this case I applaud the
move rookie too and I do like your Rook
B1 too and the question you asked is a
Salient one is this ending where you've
kind of voluntarily dinged your Pawns
um
a win or not I don't know uh would you
feel my king needs to run Sprint Sprint
Sprint to the queen side everybody is a
King Sprints to the Kings this looks
closer to a drawer I want to say but I'm
not sure I'm just not sure yes sir yes
please I have a small question in the
position before rookie 2 was played
let's say I will make a natural move
Rook B8 because this is not even the
line suggested by the computer but after
Rook B1 what if I play Rook B5
right uh interestingly enough I think
this was precisely the position that
Alexandra was trying to avoid which was
you know blockading in front if you will
I guess uh the move that she didn't like
was Rook C1 threatening yeah threatening
the back rank made and I guess we're up
to C5
and again if I get to play B5 in your
Rook is passive
uh but I understand what you're saying
uh with the remove Rook B5 uh how am I
going to break
uh the block blockade but I think Rook
C1 and Rook C8 is what Alexandra didn't
like
okay yeah sure by the way Queen maybe
she wants to go to some Queen ending
because now that after Nana two conjun
through with the h-born white king
cannot easily hide from the Perpetual
check ideas like Queen D1 Queen H5
ah sorry say that again please I was
just refreshing myself I'm saying that
maybe Alexandra wants to play the Queen
ended right with possible Perpetual
checks Queen D1 Queen H5 because Nana
two conjured through with the H Pawn
right exactly so uh
um
let's say here I just just to put your
yeah just to put your position uh up on
the board so no I'm doing it wrong how
do I allow what I want to say is that
thanks to White's Pawn structure you are
vulnerable to a Perpetual check between
H5 and the D1 squares what what you
wanted but uh okay she's going for the
queen ending and this one but you just
demonstrated that it's very hard for
white to put the queen on such a bad
square right okay so Queen takes E1 so
let's see uh Alexandra thing 23 here or
Queenie too yeah Alexandra thinks that
this queen ending offers her better
chances I'm not sure she's right in my
view if I get to play G4 and G3 then I'm
going to go Queen check and queen C6 so
I'll have my king on the long diagonal
and you won't have any
um right Perpetual checking ideas so
again if I'm in uh Nano shoes I want to
play G4 G3
setting up so that there's no Perpetual
checks and then I want to bring my queen
to the C6 Square by the way they just
reached mufoli so they will get
additional 30 minutes and Nana will
figure out where to put her queen and
the King to avoid all the checks and
convert this game
and for
for Nana what a relief this position is
she knows she's playing for two results
and out of the opening she seemed to be
playing uh a game of suicide I would
almost say she was in real real real
trouble so what a turnaround this has
been what about Arena's position
her Advantage if they also reached the
time control by the way uh yes they just
made him 40. Knight F7
check
and uh oh I was about to say everything
exactly Arena has got a very
straightforward win on the Eureka
uh will not have a good answer for the
move Rook fa chat yeah right it's just
simply to win any of this end game but
we should jump to Bella's game because
that's the only game that still hasn't
reached to move 40. okay and I think
Elizabeth blundered again she had she
had the draw
but now we when we left it we left it in
this position
and take take take on H3 and you said
and now sorry to G4 is a fantastic move
which you may have missed oh
oh the old but I think Knight B3 was
already going in the wrong direction
she could have played Rook C2 here
after Knight F1 yeah no Knight F1 Rook
C2 makes perfect keep the night on a
very good Square on D4
okay
um I'm gonna have to play Rook H3 Rook
takes B2 exactly Rook takes H3 Rook
takes B2
and it E3 Rook E2
picking up A3
I was I was hoping to just distract you
on the D5 uh Pawn that uh
I I did not
rats be careful 1995 here
95.
is there yes
it's raining for white so but you have a
more precise move here after didn't
expect to Checkmate three you can
introduce yes Rook B3 actually is a more
precise move here
Rook B3 yes or B3 because after Knight
D5 then you can make a ridge G3 check
and then this coverage yes and then you
were yes you're taking the Knight on Z5
which gotcha okay
um by the way those f6s
one minute
Elizabeth still has two moves to make
Bella needs one more that it's this move
G4 that's rocked Elizabeth's world
because this double attack of G4 takes
F5 by the way talk about meeting Nets
the you know yeah that that is a mass of
Pawns uh enveloping uh black king G4
takes F5 and Rook takes B3 uh how does a
computer assess this 10 seconds nine
seconds
seven
check 61 he is the best continuation of
course but con the computer thinks that
why it is raining so let's have a look
Rook C1 King F2
Rook C2 yep
then King F3 King F3
no yes because stepping in the way of
the rock huh but
then 90 to check after
92.2 right
not obvious once again but the winning
move according to the computer Aid I
just saw the line is Rook H4 and I'm
trying to understand it yes you Force
black to take on G4 but what if any
other Rook moves let's say what if I try
Rook okay it's crazy yes but after Rook
H6 actually it seems that the position
is equal let's say let's understand Rook
H4 he gives us winning but ifrook H6
is it because black can win the G4 Pawn
uh yes because Rook D3 yes King G2 and
then even if you go on g2a you can
repeat so Rook this two can give three
and Rook D3
by the way have the players reach time
yeah they just made move 40. okay
but I know computer said King F3 is
winning but why not just King D3 here it
seems simpler to me team David three do
I have Rook F2
Knight G3
93 I took us
no more made huh I had a five check
oh that's pretty you don't see a meeting
that like that every day that is very
pretty no King G4 no King E4 nice nice
cat and you don't have King f8 but he do
have King G8 okay
and then I don't know how I'm doing it
oh okay
um Knight H6 check take on G4 Knight H6
check King G7 Knight takes G4 Rook I'm
gonna miss that F4 Pawn you sure are
yeah that uh
that's uh the foundation of the
structure
um
wow and this is such a huge game for our
standings as both the ladies you see
their point totals
their Elizabeth Pates uh with three and
a half points and Bella with three
um the outcome of this game is going to
really impact the standings
King F3 is that the own oh hold on so we
we just been looking at King D3 Rook F2
so King F3
is that the only winning move well it's
just that the advantage is much much
bigger in this line but let's have a
look at the variation that you were
analyzing so sure King G3 Rook F2 okay
King D3 Rook okay and then the computer
suggests G takes a five
wow
sacrificing a night yes you sacrifice
the night so Rook takes F1 then G6
I'm threatening Rook H7 so I'm forced to
capture on G6 then F6 wow
yeah I gotta back up and E6 here
is this winning for one well it's plus
one so let's have a look only now can
you well can you take on everything of
course not because after E7 yes you're
winning right
then Knight C5 Knight C5 check King E2
King E2 and Rook F4
is
seven no E7 is actually losing so F7
yeah
but then
G7 Rook H7 right King H7 and E7 I think
this is the end of the line it seems
like some kind of study but by the way
even though I'm queening am I winning
that I think that's why it's only plus
one right yeah I mean you make a queen
but Rook at night I feel like I've got
some chances of holding this uh crazy
game you also have the d-pawn you can
push it to D3 and then
there will always be a problem for
whites right wow uh
I don't want to say three results but it
just feels uh it's not
easy for Bella at all I just want to put
it like that and that variation that you
just cited that's crazy so she needs to
find King F3 and Rook H4 King F3 Knight
D2 check Knight takes D2 Rook takes D2 I
don't have time to take because in this
game in this case my king is no longer
in the Square
uh yeah exactly I'm not in the Square so
black actually wins that cave so I have
to play the move Rook H4
and the idea is that any trades well I
can happily accept a trade maybe even I
can take with the King now actually and
okay thanks B2 well here I think my my
pawns just
of course there's three against one
yeah that that's uh that's that's enough
so you can't take but you could play
Rook check
yeah okay King F2 takes you take with
the Rook
yes yes and what is this
I'm trying to play actively
oh Rook G3 here
oh okay two you want it you want to play
rough huh yeah one and you can win the
d-pawn
and even King F3
boy this is this is a tough tough rule I
think it's very welcome in King F5
uh just a second what king F3 King F5 G6
[Laughter]
take on G3 oh you have G takes f
oh let me show you what you might have
missed yeah
and the point is I'm threatening to
yeah nicely done wow just a second let
me give myself a kiss
remember at the board when you see
variations that charm you be be kind to
yourself you go wow that's a really nice
like you calculated well right so uh
when you see variations like this let it
give you confidence you know trust
yourself I think it's easy to find this
lines when you know there is a win when
someone tells you you have a win you
just have to find it yeah but nobody
if you're winning and when you see an
artificial line like this looking after
a little cage four you don't really
trust that line
I don't know I counted a lot of material
uh by the way counting a lot of material
I'm in the game between harika and arena
for just a second because they followed
that line all the way to the end Rook
takes King takes and irina's thinking
because up only one Pawn but the thing
is she has three connected passphones
and that's why it's easily winning too
connected
yes but I agree with you and she's
easily winning thanks to the two
connected passphones and the fact that
this Pawn is backwards and always
vulnerable to a captured but yes King C3
F4 get get those doggies going uh play
F4 E4
up the board push a baby
uh would you
how would you
stop yourself from playing Rook takes A7
and Rook G2 would would you not think
that maybe you were winning this Rook
ending with white yeah
no I mean it's I don't see how I'm not
winning
that you are winning yes yeah that's
what I'm saying so in this position do
you make the decision to take on A7 or
do you make the decision to play King C3
I think I would go to K7 you would yes
and so Rook takes A7 Rook here King C3
Rook takes would you play Rook C6 or
Rook C7 or before I might take it back I
thought I was winning C6 as well after
Rook C7 I was going to go Rook F7 but
this is actually a very funny ending I
like it looks King is cut off
well I wanted to say after the move B5
Bella won a game where she had two
connected past pawns against an outside
pass pause right this is that would be
her third time
but she'll get the two connected pass
pawns against the outside pass pawn and
maybe yeah yeah I would feel that uh
that whites
another endgame technique uh wow
we confused the players right but this
is the current position in Arena I would
play King C3 uh myself I like just
nursing the Pawns of the board bring my
king over and I like the fact that this
A7 Pawn stuck you might end up having to
play passively with your rook and I like
my active Rook so I would play King C3
the players have made time control very
very nice and Bella has made move King
F3 we'll see now if she will find Rook
H4 as well
after Knight D2 checks and I think
Knight D2 is basically box right they're
forced what about
fun okay well 93 it looks very
unpleasant
I want to go D3 but I'm allowing Knight
F5 so that's exactly no way why it's not
winning here exactly Knight takes F5 10
G8 let's try it it's not working
all the way to the end let's go
um okay first of all I can always and
that that's reassuring that I have this
move Knight E3 to deal but uh why don't
I have
my Pawn what's the clearest way exactly
you want to push some G6 or is this has
to be something here exactly exactly how
can I I mean magically put my Pawn on F6
so that I have a meeting that
it's not that simple you have or you
know
should I tell you yes yes
I was very quiet voice
tell us a nice bedtime story put us to
sleep exactly exactly uh here in Knight
F5 is actually a mistake
yes gets equal once again because you
have to play night they try to put the
Knight on F6 because you cannot go on a
fade because of Knight F6 yes it's
completely winning
but then after Knight H5 F takes G4 so
we're in check no negative yes here yes
GTX F5 king of five now you have
nice so you can no longer go I think
onto six so the computer suggests rookie
Sixth and Rook H6 yes King D5 so Rook D6
makes all the difference yes square and
then Rook C6 and that's how you stop
the pawn yes everything is because when
Knight C5 you have Knight E4 I I think
so 92 you can simply take it so yeah
very very nice variation and it starts
with Knight H5 check
um but actually after Knight F5 that's
what I wanted to show you here in this
position and G3 if you take Knight F5
look at the evolution it drops almost to
well to zero nothing yeah so after King
and here it is after King G8 the
computer evaluates this position is
equal so it's not so easy to stop the
d-pawn here so
yeah
D2 Knight E3 and you will have to give
the Knight away if uh right and then
white could lose this you know yes
exactly because black can try Knight D4
here so rookie four a king E4 and rookie
one hello yes
three right but you still have this
smooth King G3 Rook E3 and King D2 crazy
variation nice
wow uh but I I really like this uh
Knight H5 check and Knight F6
um very early in my career uh looking at
the chessboard as a battlefield and I
came up with this idea that there are
prime squares for pieces and when you're
white the the F6 and the C6 squares are
the best squares for the Knight or F3
and C3 if you're black and the E4 and
the D4 squares are the best for the
bishop
right those squares you control the most
uh you you attack the most number of
squares from but he got seduced by the
Free Pawn on F5 I did I did I did I did
uh please maybe foreign in this position
can black just go D3
uh in the position that we the actors
are checking F3 yes
D3 here uh the computer suggests G takes
df5 so G2 then Knight E3 looks not even
check huh wow C1 yes but all these
variations have to be calculated because
it's not so obvious to a human mind for
example that E6 is actually winning six
so yes let's have a look E6 because if
you make maybe a more natural move
something like Rook H6 but then yes the
same ideas through Knight D4 and rookie
one as we so I think in the previous
line like last time we were going to put
our Rook on the D file but the Knight D4
check blocks The Rook that's a that's a
very nice uh variation let's have a look
at E6 right so if you play Knight D4
here King King E4 and well this is no
longer true because you can you cannot
play I think rookie one here
because you will have F6
that's why you need to play uh question
If instead of E6 white plays more
natural looking move F6 check is that
not winning anymore let's try F6 and
look yeah yeah I saw the evaluation drop
uh I was hoping I had Knight of 597
still Checkmate but D1 is comes with a
check check yes yeah so but how does it
go after E6 is still ah he wants after F
takes C6 to play immediately F6 yes so I
think that this position has to be
played with a Tempo all the time so E6 F
takes C6 F6 and so if you play King Jade
here and now you play G6 right and you
cannot Parry all the threads here of the
F7 check and uh promoting the pawn wow
some great stuff I love it uh Bella and
Elizabeth in the current position
Elizabeth thinking overnight D2 check
what is that Rook component and game
going to be like after trades Rook H4
she's thinking about D3 and you know who
gets there first with the most because
he wants also an option and Rook C1
difficult choices as the players have
made time control let's go back to the
game of uh Nana and Alexandra this is
the queen ending and uh
a little bit of a surprise to me that
the pawn isn't already on G4 and G3 I
think it hasn't been provoked so ah no
need for it yet right oh by the way I
noticed that now with the queen on B8
it's all about Sheltering my king right
and with the queen on B8 maybe I can
even just put my Pawn on F3 and trundle
because there's no propettes
uh
uh well wait a minute hold on my my Pawn
was supposed to be on I'm calling from
B4 to D1 exactly uh so and I was going
to stop you from going to be one I
thought she was going to put her Pawn on
F3 so that she could put upon on G4 and
her King on H2 and no purpets right but
black doesn't even have quindy one yet
so correct so there's no reason to rush
she's played in the game Queen C7 check
King e so now she can just push B6
P6 because again if the queen was on D1
we'd have the Perpetual check pattern
that we're also familiar with with Keane
Queen D6 please take the coin
six
I just want to make sure because your
king is going to be so far away sure
that might also be uh yeah it's just a
little bit worried that uh could it no I
mean I'd need my Pawn on F5 in order to
you know what I mean we're my way up the
board uh the queen D6 I think is
actually uh legit right because I'm also
threatening quindy one as before correct
yes
so also Queen H4 just in case
it's covered in the H5 check right so
that and then B7 yeah so that in this
case whether I go Queen F1 or or queen
H4 yeah Queen H4 I should be nana should
be winning this game arena what did she
do she chose she took on A7 to take on
A7 because she's winning another Pawn I
forgot about this member k6 me too shame
on me shame on both of us they'd like to
win the pawn that way that's pretty easy
yeah that's a that's a nice one can play
King T8 rookie six King C7 it should be
lost of course but really you can't
display the technique exactly keep
kicking uh Rook to E2 King Rook to B2 at
least my my Rook will be uh
passively placed on a fourth if I have
to do it that way it should be a long
end game truly and finally before we go
on break let's just once again check in
on ballot no Elizabeth after this move
King F3 uh definitely stuck but it does
look like we're gonna get some very
seriously nice uh decisive games uh as
we return from our break on the other
side we'll see you soon
meet me at the beauty the beauty in
Forest Park the muni's premier season
bursting with comedy's romance and Magic
Begins June 12th with the muni premiere
of beautiful the Carole King musical
the Epic summer continues with Disney's
Beauty and the Beast chess West Side
Story Little Shop of Horrors rent and
Sister Act
single tickets are now on sale at
muni.org
in forest
Park hello everyone I'm here with Dr
Jeannie sinkfield uh thank you so much
for accepting to be interviewed by me uh
the tournament the Karen's cup which I
know it's named after you it's set to
start very soon today and I would like
to ask you a few questions about
um maybe your um how did you feel when
you the club in a way decided to name
the tournament after you
I kept trying to persuade them they
didn't need to
because we already had a singfield cup
but this is sort of cool yeah I've gone
into it you know it it was a time we
needed the top women players to be
celebrated
I agree and um I'm very appreciated with
that it's great
um for me as a chess player and also for
the chess fans to see more female
tournaments being played but those who
are like you know you see the you know
the best men players are actually the
best best players but the women's
tournaments
it is just so much more fun they're
faster and they're Do What I Call things
that you know some of the top players
may not would find too risky but the
women are going we're we're just going
to do this crazy stuff you're going to
get confused you're breaking out of time
and I'm going to beat you I think I'm
just a little bit more fun you know so
you think
um because you also you know you know to
places I know you often mentioned the
story about how you introduce uh Rex to
to chess no no no no Rex is playing
breakfast racing and orphanage you learn
how to play when he was in the orphanage
okay and then he played in high school
and then he played as long as we were
dating and married he's been playing
since he was a little a little boy you
know we start playing a little bit when
we first got married but I decided that
he cared more about it than I do I see
I I thought maybe I misunderstood
oftentimes when you're telling the story
that uh I beat him but that was many
many you're we've been married 50 years
and that was before we got married
because last time I was able to eat him
okay and now it's now I don't even price
okay well maybe maybe you can take some
you know lessons to surprise him a
little bit with some some opening do you
have an opening did you
I I wrote the booklet learn to read
your reads yes
and that was when I learned literacy I
see so now you know when I was in my 70s
but I just play a lot of people
worldwide just play for fun
they don't write it down but if you want
to play Inner tournament right you want
to replay your games you want to read
books
I figured out how the literacy I could
get better but there were no booklets
yes so now we got it for those of you
out there they're 13 languages okay I
know there is a language that's not
covered okay and Europe great chess
player I need translators all the people
you see translated
did it for free yes it's a very nice and
took it back to their countries
so this year
in in the fall there were Ukrainian
Chess Federation is using Christian
Silas translation into
yeah and I'm sorry you Romanian Romanian
Romanian sorry there's so many languages
yes in the schools yes so they're going
to have
a booklet the read and write that you
wrote so that a lot a lot of players who
maybe don't have two coaches
if they can learn the literacy
they can run books they can replay their
game do you see yes that is very
important and the rich kids might have
coaches the rural kids maybe not so much
this is just a way of
getting everybody getting everybody to
play and everyone is invited is the kind
of game that anyone can play at any
female male any age
as long as you're you know passionate
about the game you can keep keep going
on now in St Louis there was a a pro
football player who's hired and he was
helping the football teams Denise
Johnson he just passed away he was
requiring every football player to learn
to play chess because he felt that it
taught them how to conceptualize
their Roots it's not very nice that is
very nice Definitely if anyone
speaks one of the languages that does
not have the booklet translated please
do contact the sandwiches club and we'll
try to get it we'll we'll get it
together and translate in another
language and make it accessible to as
many people in the world the latest
languages are Swahili
Armenian who's deck nice very nice
Russian there's Indonesian my legs there
are lots of lots of languages hopefully
some new ones will be contacting us I
don't know they just keep showing up you
know people get jealous because so and
so I think we're gonna get George in
soon okay that would be very nice I
wanna I really appreciate you joining me
for this very short interview and I want
to ask you one last question about the
Karen's cup uh there are 10 players
playing in this tournament
um you might not be willing to answer
this question but do you have any
favorites
to win this Well I obviously for the
American side you know Irina would be
nice okay so you just don't know you
don't know you don't you know it's been
a little bit of a while because of the
covet and of course it's been two years
new players that
are brand new that's right and remember
the singfield cup is won by an 18 year
old
[Music]
you know what he did starting at 12. he
listened to all the online video that
the chess club puts out and watched all
the commentary for the game so when he
came here it's like he had been playing
these players for years that's right so
you out there you can learn from these
players maybe one day unfortunately it's
in English but you know but that helps
with the language learning too if you
don't speak the language and you try
your best to understand the chess and
kind of listen to the commentary maybe
you get the chance to learn yeah in
English you know because you gotta
listen to yasu Sarah Juan yes no that's
right and maybe some of the jokes don't
translate that is true that is true well
I do appreciate you being here I hope
there's gonna be beautiful games like
you're saying attacking games fun
fasting let's hope let's hope they'll be
that and for future Generations female
chess players who are aspiring to come
to this tournament May maybe do
something similar as dalireza was doing
follow the live broadcast try to learn
the moves learn the players and come
here in a few years and try to win the
competition
you thank you very much Dr Jeannie I
really appreciate the interview and
looking forward to the event I came to
and come to St Louis just capital of the
U.S of course thank you so much
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game landmarked by the
world's largest chess piece sitting
outside our front door the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy including various exhibitions
monthly concerts and much more whether
you are a beginner or a professional
there is something for everyone to learn
here at the World Chess Hall of Fame
enjoy free admission to our rotating
exhibitions in our Galleries and sign up
for chess events family-friendly
programming and art classes and don't
forget to stop by our award-winning gift
shop Q Boutique and Shop a wide
selection of Chess related merchandise
for more information on current exhibits
please visit worldchess hof.org
[Music]
thank you
welcome back everyone so far we have one
result it was a drop between Abdul Malik
and Mama Tara
lots of games in progress but lots of
results it looks like uh as a number of
decisive uh games all decisive results
we're expecting indeed and I just like
this move this last move that Nana has
played in her game with Alexandra this
move King H2 basically saying you're not
going to get any kinds of Perpetual
checks and in the meanwhile I've got a
runaway passer that you cannot deal with
her last move I like this move a lot if
you
if you rush this is like you feel this
incredible feeling of absolute anger and
disgust with yourself a desire to flip
the table I have the desire to flip the
board do not allow the Perpetual check
but this move King H2 sidesteps all of
that invites the move Queen takes F2 and
now after
B7 if you try once again to set up this
mechanism I do have a check you'll go
back I do make a a queen and I'll have
Queen H3 to block the check so very nice
move King H2 by Nana and boy what a
comeback she had because her opening was
simply atrocious what about uh Bella
when we left it uh Elizabeth is still oh
no she did played the move Rook C1 so in
this particular position we were
mesmerized by both Knight D2 check
D3 and Rook there was like three really
important moves that uh
Elizabeth had to choose from she chose
Rook C1 but it was pointed out to us
after Knight G3
D3 do not play Knight takes F5 check
that throws away the Lion's Share of
your advantage rather bring your knight
to the F six square and trackmates and
uh set up a checkmating pattern that
we're all familiar with Rook check and
rookie at the end this looks so risky
because that d-pawn is now completely
unstepable right so unless there is for
sure a Checkmate Black's about to have
an extra Queen except there's a pusher
jacket but Bella has to make sure that's
right too yeah she does indeed so but
she's got to see in this moment and it's
I mean it's a hidden uh right because
you're so attracted to Knight takes F5
with a chat Knight F5 also looks like
I'm creating a Checkmate
this is a this is really terrible that
you get to this position and you're kind
of stunned that you don't have some
wonderful breakthroughs that do provide
you with a Checkmate but the night is
just misplaced on that five it needs to
be on F6 So In This Moment it's Knight
to G3 to H5 which will bring Bella
victory in our third game how's Arena
doing
she is she is converting the end game
with two extra pawns and when we left it
she just played the move rookie rookie
Asics she picked up the pawn indeed and
you're right two extra pawns should be
good enough for sure
yes even if she splits the pawns let's
say she plays D5 B and E are winning too
but D5 King D6 I I agree with you
completely yeah this was winning right
yes uh yeah just oh actually on King D6
I'll take on C6
no
that is
uh very attractive oh okay one okay
not to
get scared shish kebab
and reminding everybody Anna zetanski
our tournament leader had a buy today
yes she's resting today watching the
others play and tomorrow she'll be
playing Jean Saya Abdul Malik
first round big matchup against Irina
Crush I mean all of the
clashes that have taken place between
Anna and Arena over the years and to
think that the Karen's cup 2023 could
very well be decided in the last round
wow and Anna enjoys a one-point lead and
if she can finish it plus three she's
currently plus three she finishes a plus
three It's a grand master norm and uh
yes in round eight if she wins she will
secure
definitively the Grand Master title and
to remind everyone our schedule on
Sunday players will play round eight
Monday is the last round round nine
unless
there's necessary playoffs which will be
on the next day on Tuesday June 13th
exactly
um and what have you got for Samira
well I'm still waiting for the move here
because I think this position is the
most interesting one so sure
93 is a winning blind and I try to find
something different here so let's say
can you make another move then D3 and
then enter this line with Knight H5 but
what if I take on G4 try to make your
king go farther away yes exactly so
taken G4 King stage G4 and now D3
yeah yeah either of those moves
apparently yes are winning so let's try
the most obvious one so Knight H5 King
f8 ah nice Yes actually here yes yeah
so I thought then
black is actually running out of
resources here after Nigeria well it has
to be D3 and you just hope that your
opponent does not see Knight h
five check
so King G6
take on the five and that's the same
variation where the Rook
H6
I think G7 Rook G6 D2 D2 actually that
was not the variation that we analyzed I
think you go Knight H5 check and Knight
F6 again you don't even need Rook D6 ah
you mean after Knight G3 yes yes no oh
we actually haven't analyzed this
variation I think that was the other
line where you your Rook was going Rook
H6 or the six Rook c6s when the King was
on D5 and on C4 it's another Lane let's
try F5 here but then wow yes I think
well why not you can you cannot take it
seriously of course that's me so F5 King
G7 now you can play Knight H5 with the
same idea and negative six
you get the move F5 is a free extra
attention yes and Rook h8 so yes
with a very important threat yes made is
made exactly yes and I don't think that
there's anything you can do here so
maybe this is a very
clean line here so it's five yes and
then Knight H5 and Knight F6
absolutely thank you Almera very nice
I'm looking at uh the game of Alexandra
for just a moment after King H2
Alexander is laying the cunning trick
she wants to offer her Queen trade like
and normally think normally speaking
going into a king and pawning game with
an extra Pawn you think you're winning
uh that you might be uh ruthfully uh
surprised but unfortunately for
Alexandra that her her best trick
unfortunately will not bring her success
Queen play Queen B5 here still
threatening uh Perpetual the uh prepared
right check
see and then just be seven right yes but
but hold on uh let's not give it up yet
check hear back
right Queen G4
oh dear Queen G4 I I'm afraid that I
will maintain the pawn and then that's
uh that's good enough so yeah Queen G4
nicely done nicely done uh Nasi
nice I mean Nana did 99 I just found it
the Final Touch
what Amira calls the delicate touch the
delicate yes Queen takes D7 I didn't
really understand why this queen takes
D7 wins of course it wins this oh really
yeah I thought it was a beautifully laid
trap Queen why does Queen D7 Kings the
pure King is so far away let's say G4
I'll then I'll bring my king So G4 King
King G3 you will have to play G6 yes at
a certain moment no King age four I
think is that yeah yes it's very
important and then after
black plays G6 you will play F4 and F5
and then you just uh warm your way into
the position this way
yeah it's winning but requires
calculation oh and we are too tired
oh
and I imagine so is Nana so she played
Queen B8
okay
five and I have a Tempo G3 or G4 yeah
nice
and to quote Tom I'm
Queen B8 though was uh I want to say
Nana's choice and I
I can't fault her but I do like your
idea of at least uh you know before one
last Cheapo uh before I give it a rest
Queen B5 and I've I've been pounding the
table for some time to get the pawn to
G4 I think that also is a good a good
way of just avoiding the patterns there
by the way in Bella's game we don't have
9g3
let's do it Knight G3 but okay moment
the key moment is here after D3 which
way does the night go well we fell for
it first let's be fair I mean if Bella
plays Knight takes F5 she'll have only
been repeating our mistake
uh the actual nicely winning line is
Knight H5 check so that after King f8
you put your knight on the F6 Square so
you support mates on E8 as well as G8 uh
patterns that were very very funny and
it's crazy that black can't run even
here if I start with King E7 you still
have okay shade and I don't have King V6
or anything I'm still mated exactly
that indeed is the case uh gotcha Knight
and Rook a very strong combination yeah
you know it was uh interesting for me
that they called this the Arabian mate
The Rook at night combination
um over the many many many centuries of
Chess over the years
um the nomenclature of Chess is really
interesting like for me I'm really upset
with the world of Chess you know we have
these Sports where a player scored
touchdowns and they make goals in chess
we have checkmate
yeah right what kind of combination of
words are Checkmate and it comes from
the Farsi the words in Farsi for King is
Shah
the Shah of Iran yeah so in chess when
you attack your opponent's king you're
supposed to say check right Shah you're
Sha Sha and when the king is dead in
Farsi is Shah Mott that's very similar
because in Russian
and check the mate is mad
is
chess
I confused myself but
and in Russian how do you say checkmate
yeah so Sharma
and just to remind everybody about
what's coming up after the Karen's cup
Magnus is back he will play in the Super
United rapid and Blitz in Zagreb Croatia
July from third to 10th exactly as the
grand Chester
picks up and later in the year we will
also have of course the rapid and Blitz
here in St Louis as well as the
sinkfield cup well let's take a look at
the whole schedule in fact so you can
see how to plan your vacation so
upcoming events the first tournament
will be the rapid and Blitz Instagram
Croatia after that in San Luis there
will be U.S Juniors and seniors
championships let's break that down
there's going to be the U.S girls and
then the U.S Juniors open so girls are
qualified for the junior open but
they'll be the girls juniors and seniors
right and then in September there will
be chest nine elex that's Bobby Fischer
chess for those of your chess 960.
however there will be U.S men's and
women's championships but I think I'll
change my roles and I'll be the player
oh we'll miss you we'll miss you but
then you can come back and tell us how
you won the game yes there okay sounds
good we've got a plan all right and how
is Bella doing because uh this is the
this is the key moment coming in
Elizabeth is down to six and a half
minutes she hasn't played D3 yet what
maybe she sees that Knight H5 is winning
well yes but it's sort of like
you know you've got to test your
opponent right and there's there's no
other really testing move sorry is there
a tricky move maybe I start with the
king move King f8 just to
provoke Knight takes at five so start
with King f8 f8 no here you wouldn't
play Knight H5 that looks no no I would
play Rook H.A check for sure because I
would be thinking if I could bring my
Rook to d8 I'll be dealing with your
past Pawn so I would go like rook d8 and
king seven yeah no 77 yes I I broke my
Rook behind but if you go King to E7
well then I can take on right with the
champ King D7
came to D7 and she has played D3 so
she's Moment of Truth yes exactly Bella
well you find Knight H5 here uh I'm
actually looking at
I think maybe you can take the fourth
pawn and then sack the ninth for the
pawn so like Rook f8 or something yeah
it feels like I should have I I wouldn't
be surprised if you know moves like G6
were also winning but this is the key
moment she's played Knight G3
D3 we know that Knight H5 is the winning
move but again I just want to emphasize
we we stop we we looked at Knight F5
first yeah just to remind everyone in
this position where we're sitting and
analyzing Knight F5 and we couldn't find
a win for a couple minutes and then
elmira's like should I tell you she was
anxious to tell us I mean she was like
oh I have a secret I want to share with
and the problem is is that there wasn't
any
beauty uh follow-up which is surprising
yeah and the whole point is that after
Knight E3 there it's not that I'm going
to happily win your night I'm gonna play
rookie one and I'm gonna make it very
awkward for you to give up your night
for my Pawn so that's why Knight H5 to
F6 is the winning move
and let's just drop in on the Nana
versus Alexandra game as we think
resignation's imminent here oh yes it is
good call
well done just a second let me give
myself a patent on the back
as wow Alexandra is going to look
ruthfully back on this game and say why
why didn't I capture on C4 why did I
play D6 yeah the chance to have such a
huge advantage in the opening with the
black pieces doesn't happen at all no
it's it's so rare and it's such an
important match exactly definitely
disappointing for Alexandra but what a
relief for Nana and indeed uh for Nana
very much so and Irina she did go for
that uh D5 move that you suggested
because she knows that the two ons are
definitely uh winning I which game did I
have it I believe it was a U.S
championship game I think against Vitaly
zoltzman I have lost yeah and I thought
for some reason don't ask me why I
thought a position like this I had some
defensive chances that I really did not
and he wanna he won a majority game very
exactly I think the only time two split
pawns are a draw it's when a and C or F
and H right exactly bishop and Rook
bones yeah but uh this one is is really
well gone I mean and you just have to
decide which Pawn you want to escort up
the board and good news Bella did play
Knight H5 well good news for ballast
fans
985 on the board and Elizabeth played
King G6 King G6 Pawn takes on the board
King takes on the board I think Bella
still needs to make the accurate move
that Almira suggested Knight G3
I think
I think yeah definitely and she's done
it so this was the line where somehow
the king took a a a a walk
uh over to the D file
can you say four king C4 Rook C6
probably
Knight C5
I think it was 90. my king is very close
to the D3 Pawn exactly exactly so
uh Knight G3 checked on the board
and kidney six really is the only move
here but uh for Bella
I mean this is extraordinary I mean how
do you start the tournament with two
losses and you snap back with four wins
I have an easy explanation for that
please terrible terrible jet lag Darrell
well that explains the two losses tell
me how you get the four wins uh we'll
put it in the account for a million
bucks that's just her being a very
strong Grandmaster
be it and once again our results so far
we have two results uh jeansai abdomale
I want to say a they're called dispute
that ended in a in a standoff draw yeah
and then just defeated Alexandra Costa
nyuk huge result huge result for
customers that really uh really hurts
two games remaining we think Arena has
got a technical win and we think uh
Bella is the life of the ball she's got
uh her fourth winner in a row
if she can just guide this uh game to
the victory I mean today's game was
pretty Rocky it went back and forth yes
yes uh at times I even felt there was a
three result game but once again uh you
got to give Elizabeth a lot of credit
because she had a terrible opening she
just this move E4 rocked her and she
fought back
to nearly Save the King yeah she
certainly did four minutes 30 seconds
here
well it's not the the clock that's the
problem it's the it's the position
and if King goes through G6 then F5 was
winning right
yes that was the nice move F5 check we
get to sneak in F5
and that's why uh and look how
confidently Bella's playing
she expected this move King E6 and she
pounced uh immediately Rook H6 check
King
has to go to D5
you go to
e75 comes with a check yeah so King
Rook check
King
and Rook check any trades of Rooks will
just mean that the g-pawn will promote
after E6 some Pawn breakthrough
yeah this looks really
really nice and once again uh your best
streak
my best friend of grand Masters uh top
players not just winning an open
tournament 5-0 or something like that
but yeah your best streak I don't think
it was more than plus three really I
can't remember well against strong
players yeah in the youth World Youth
and European youth tournaments I used to
play sometimes I had seven wins in a row
right yeah but again strong players not
more than plus three okay because it's
very hard it's very very very hard yeah
and that's why for many of us that Bobby
Fischer streak of winning 6060 and the
interzone also that he had a 20. Fabi
did it once also seven yeah seven
against the strongest players in the
world brilliant brilliant I love that uh
here in St Louis for the singville cup
16 2015. I'm not sure which year it was
and we say this end game that's
you silly winning
but it's not fast she has to make slow
improvements exactly
and uh as Arena makes slow improvements
we have a guest in studio with El Mira
thank you yes sir I enjoyed in the
studio by Nana jagnitzel congratulations
you just won a very complicated game and
one thing that I wanted to do today I
switched off the computer because I want
I really want to understand well all the
lines that you've been calculating were
you surprised by C5
no actually
she had one game
this move with C5 but
I don't know computer evaluate this
position after E4 the white is white has
a big Advantage but during the game I
don't know maybe after Bishop D6 I
should shouldn't have played Bishop E3
when she
Bishop D3 I remember computer was
showing this but I don't know Bishop D6
right right yes Bishop D6 is a very good
boom but did you evaluate uh or consider
this year
and okay Knight c3p takes C3
and uh
I don't know d65 or something like this
so I was thinking oh this is okay this
but uh
I want me to switch the computer's music
because I remember that if a computer
was suggesting E4 and I played D4
but I don't know I'm during the game it
was very difficult to to play this
position I I was worse when I played
Bishop C7
after Bishop C7 yeah
I think instead of Queen E8 Queen I
didn't like Queen yes for me yes
yeah and I'm bad very bad position
after cleaning it I don't know I got
some some ideas related Knight D6
somewhere so I went
I was thinking here castle and also 96
okay so castle castle D5 yeah okay so
it's not maybe 96 yeah 96 I have to play
we shot the six yeah I was calculate
this bishop F 3G takes F3 Knight C6 I
was calculated yes but I didn't have a
choice I got such a position that um
I I didn't have much choice so I went on
this way well it happened during this
game but when it happens in general do
you talk to yourself during the game
yes sometimes they are when I'm
too disappointed yes I'm talking to
myself yes I wanted well to know but
okay so let's I think that here nice
nice things telling to us she made well
so I uh here I already got some chances
yeah which of the six
I didn't know I don't know what was her
idea when she played physics but here I
have already normal position
so then you played rather accurately
here so and yeah here I have a bit even
a bit advantage and after 1983 is a very
good very good yeah later on
maybe not night before is not accurate
here you know what I was thinking Bishop
H6 said midnight D4 idea but uh still
like like my position a bit
so 94 and 94 here yes I have this D6
Square for my knight
somewhere
so yeah
sorry but later later I think when we
went to this
end game somewhere I
don't clear your plate perfectly yes
but uh I didn't know that my position
was such a good plus one and three I
thought it was more or less equal
uh okay let's continue 95 years
I know it is equal just computer
evaluates this this pen but you are
winning a pound in every line actually
yes yes but still I mean for human being
I think it's just true because we
exchanged this pawn and
I think her mistake was when she
exchanged the Rooks okay let's look here
this position must be draw
but okay one Rook it's it's okay but to
exchange the second pairs I think it's
already and must be much better
yes they are actually the um the
Queensland game is absolutely winning of
course and that was a better practical
chance used to
um it was I think better practical
chance for her to play Rook Rook end
games in in Queens game I think yes
you're absolutely lots of more chances
for drama so how do you feel now after
this one
um
what to say I have nothing good to say
because when I won this game with corner
and after three hours I got message from
the chief Arbiter that my result
canceled I was so shocked
I mean
I wrote immediately that I didn't agree
this and this is absolutely unfair and
this rule is totally nonsense but I mean
nothing and then against Bella for the
national another shock I got because I
think I played one of the best game
recently in the quality of the game
until City 5 was perfect I think for me
and
I got totally winning position and I
didn't play Rook h8 and queen F7
I think it was a influence of the
previous day
so yeah after that I don't know I'm
trying to survive yeah
so yeah it is what it is now I'm two
games more so
then you went all in you know and this
well it was feels already nice of course
yes it's a very complicated game so
there are a few rounds left and we hope
that you will come back even stronger
yeah I hope too thank you thank you
thank you uh Nana and I understand her
shot completely as she's talking about
her game with Bella she played such a
beautiful game all of those Quiet Moves
King G2 remember Queen Excellence
everything was beautiful she set the
table for a victory and the victory was
with checks and checks so those were the
easy moves she found all the hard moves
and then she missed rookie seven
and uh just again once again to remind
everybody that humpy uh canero our
defending Champion our number one seed
withdrew from the tournament after four
games and because she withdraws before
the halfway point is passed her result
is a null and Cathedrals yes that's
exactly right and so all of the
opponents uh in the future rounds
receive a buy and uh but essentially the
game she plays are rated yes but they
don't count for the tournament uh
standings
consolation prize for Alexandra and Nana
that at least they're still taking the
rating points on because of their
victories indeed they did and I just saw
that Bella just played a really nice
move I liked it a lot and for those of
you this is how Bella got to this
position she started with two losses
no line score I apologies I I uh
uh and three wins and she's winning it
so far but it looks like she's got a
fourth win lined up she's just played
this really nice move E6 that sets up a
back rank Checkmate upon on E6 now
protecting the D7 square that forced
Elizabeth to trade Elizabeth didn't want
to play King to the D file which would
allow Rook D6 check and take so she
played King F7 now comes Rook to D6
Elizabeth doesn't have better than D2
but this very sneaky move G6 check and
if you drop yeah King King G8 once again
oops that's the back rank mate okay he's
also Checkmate so King 8 is the only
move right and then we have uh G7 King
F7
and then a check
oops that's it that's all she wrote yeah
and never line for you please um yes I
really love this position there's still
a few tricks you know that you have to
be aware of so after E6 F takes is six
Rook takes E6 you could have tried
king of fate and after G6
Knight D4 oh so nasty D4 and D2 Adrian
gives zeros yes exactly so this is a
very beautiful move so wow Knight F5
here you need to play G7 to lure the
King on G7 then to play Knight F5 so
let's say King F7 and now I don't know
why book the six he wants to sacrifice
The Rook immediately but maybe rookie
seven here but still no I think Rook D6
is a better move here so D1
and you take G1 and
yeah
this is wow a draw so many tricks in
chess game I know it and it looks like
an innocent position too uh where you
wouldn't expect there to be this many
tricks by the way uh I noticed that
Elizabeth has just tried another little
uh chicken uh
if I play I actually have it
cheap one myself I think okay pink G2
King to G2
okay
takes Rook F6 check
s
and no matter where I move my king you
get a discover check that's a nasty
Cheapo
gosh darn it I think uh well that's
certainly yeah that takes away my my
what was yours I was hoping that you
were going to play King to G4 okay and
then I was going to give a check
and then the difference was that uh I I
put my Rook behind the g-pod so that I
could play D2 in which G6 I would take
it but I love your move King G2 in the
current position that's a really nasty
move the desired Rook F4 fails
uh completely to Rook F6 check that's
that's nasty I think they were more
likely to see King E3
still threatening juicy it does right
you
okay
no your Rook is protected I'm sorry I'm
sorry I was going to Shish Kebab your
skier you're up but uh you're right your
Rook is protected so yeah no King E3
yeah that's very human Moon too but I
like your king G2 best so this game
going heading uh for victory for Bella
Arena
also again very very slowly but
methodical uh progress as now the king
so what you do the secrets of it winning
this ending is pretty straightforward
you force the king towards one Pawn or
another if the black king was on the B6
Square then you would put your King on
E5 now with the black king on the E6
Square you uh step in in front of the
pawn and you escort is upon home so
something like Rook C5 Rook takes and
King C7 and then the B Pawn
Unstoppable Unstoppable exactly
but it's still interesting how in order
to win this end game you have to give up
one of the pawns right sooner or later
it has to be sacrificed exactly exactly
in order to push one upon home so Rook
C5
King C7 very straightforward
yeah
Victory Irina has less than three
minutes but I don't think she needs more
than that time
I was uh I I was asking her Arena that
is to say uh why she
lets her time take down to one second
and she says it's not a conscious thing
that you know she's not trying to give
her parents heart attacks or her coach a
heart attack it's just like just happens
it just happens and it's not it's not
intentional I was like but she doesn't
panic when she looks at the clock in two
seconds she just makes a move yeah with
a casual ease you know no shaking of the
hands or the table
yeah
so Rook C5
Rook takes E4
King to C7 and then the pawn Justice
try to give you checks Rook H4 yep
be safe okay seven
King oh I don't even have checks no no
more checks for you
eventually whether you uh try to come
down at the end here I do have rugby
five but King C7 and B8 will be more
than sufficient so arena is well on her
way to going and let's just see what
Bella did because she made King G3 King
G2 was the move and I thought that the
king G3 was the the Cheapo King G3
D2
but that's interesting I thought
Elizabeth's intention was to play Rook
check but G6 King E8 on the board
so if G7 that's the only check move
right
G7 Rook G1 check King F2 rookie G4 only
move and King up I'm assuming broke two
on back
maybe night back right
King F7
and now a check
King G8 only move and now which one do
we like best huh
I guess
this one maybe H5 oh actually both are
good both are pretty good right
um just gonna go wait D1 oh never mind
I'm too late Knight age six
oops D1 was with check sorry my bad
I I believed you good for you as the
Jedi mind trick oh dear sorry uh so what
have we got what have we done but I feel
like 93 and Bella is about to make it
Knight E31
[Music]
and we're covering very importantly yeah
um
embarrassing and then simply push F5 I
think yes well it's a Tempo and we're
gonna so we have to play Rook E1
and then King F2 just to protect the
Knight and then as you say F5 is going
to show up very shortly that will be
winning let's continue Knight C5
and let's just go back to Arena because
we think it's about to be a handshake
uh as when we left it no no handshake
yet
check and it will be in a famous B7 well
B7 King B6 right
won't be a check well that's true 25 I
should win them yeah right away you win
The Rook right away so yeah I was trying
to set up a nasty uh double attack
but no
so after B7 I have one more check Rook
h8
but your king comes up to C7 and then
hides on the sixth rank exactly on B6
and then Rook C8 that's it
who was the most difficult opponent for
you
yeah uh well first of all thanks for the
reminder uh I had uh I went through
quite a series uh so I come from the
Northwest and we had a Grandmaster from
Canada Peter biasis and Peter won a lot
of a lot of tournaments and I think my
first six games I lost before I started
defeating him
Peter was soon replaced by Juan Walter
Sean Brown
Walter one uh again maybe the first five
games before I started beating him
eventually Walter was replaced by one
Olf Anderson
wolf had a very very nice score against
me and I like to joke with off that if
he ever made a book my most decisive
games it would be a very thin book
there'll be four chapters devoted to to
our games and then after off there was
one Gary Kasparov I did get a win
against Gary but he got like four wins
lots of draws but yeah Gary was tough on
me yeah yeah I must say and by the way
Arena didn't go for that's very nice of
you too at least four different
opponents right they were The Blacklist
that was The Blacklist and for
yourselves
uh Almera who was your uh a hard
opponent and for me actually she's on
the screen right now it's Harry kadron
really rika's uh
she has plus four and no draws and no
draws that and no no losses no wins for
you no wins for me oh man that's hurtful
Almera yeah actually I have been going
through my games because I wanted to
know what is my result against uh the
players of this field which are yes very
strong so actually I'm not doing uh so
bad but I think my worst opponent was
arcade naidich because I had to play a
match against him and he was well
extremely strong and young
at that time so I lost and I think he's
the opponent against whom I played the
most games in my life which is very
strange because we played in the league
in league so we played the match and so
at some point when I saw him in front of
him I I told him that I can take
by the way I should also throw in one
Alexi sheroff Sheriff one quite uh uh
the early games uh with us so yeah there
have been some opponents that somehow
strangely enough I don't match up very
well and then others I match up like
incredibly well uh who was your favorite
customer
uh Valentina Gooney now really yes our
Karen's Cup champion it was incredible I
was lost in every game and I would win
every game it happened it happened five
times in classical games
to the point where I think she just
hates seeing my face right across the
board but she finally got revenge at the
Olympia she beat me once okay and for
you Almera did you have a favorite
customer
hmm
well not that I can think of because
you don't play against the same people
all the time right yes so I I struggled
to find
a good name yes a good name
but I'm just so happy to win a game
every game these days by the way Bella
is cruising she just played the move G7
and I think that's a a real uh Clincher
it's about to have another queen or
Checkmate absolutely yeah G7 on the
board
so I'm thinking King G8 right
and would you play night night at five
or night G4 is there a difference well
Knight G4 is threatening gives you two
different right actually threatening
made yeah made up so any Queen is just
mate Knight F5 also a very very strong
King G8 on the board but now on Knight
G4 I have rookie six
I think you're probably sorry it's not
like I'm I'm winning but I'm avoiding
the Checkmate for now okay and then
yeah five yeah that's that's a tough
move to handle right there
yeah so a choice I think of wins Knight
F5 or Knight G4 but after Knight F5 if I
still go rookie six
oh there's Rook d8 now this is pawns
defended on G7 exactly Knight F5 uh has
a double threat what you've just
described uh Rook Shack and queen as
well as night Jack and queen so double
threat that was her choice I think one
thing we can learn from this tournament
is that Bella is amazing in end games
true played them very well very precise
in the end games doesn't give opponents
any chances
three times we've seen that already
right
I got five and once again
uh Anna sitting there saying I'm I'm
looking really pretty I'm I'm doing very
well I'm taking nothing away from her
but she's looking behind her and Bella's
one four on in a row and Anna's probably
say Okay somebody just you know stop her
you know
as uh this move king of three that's
pretty
that that that should be enough uh the
double threat Triple Threat now of
Knight H6 rook d8 and king takes E2
should all conspire against Elizabeth we
will see a resignation very soon and
there she goes there we have it Bella
wow fourth win in a row yeah nice it's
amazing yeah and if we switch back to
irina's game we have the do you know the
name for this position that there's a
name for this theoretical yeah okay yeah
I can't remember it
um
building the bridge yeah it's called
building a bridge right yeah
um but there's uh some Grand Masters I
know I know sorry it gets late uh doing
these broadcasts but B7 and the whole
idea is that uh after a moves like uh
Rook I'll say rookie three I keep my
Rook there
let you out easily okay so Rook A3 I'll
give you a check yes that check is
important kicking my kick farther away
and I will play a little bit here and
then I'll go here yeah
and
look see one oh excuse me I meant to
play xc1
apologies for that King B6
rug in here next move is Rook D5 Rook B5
exactly
you just refresh my board for a moment
as we have a different position on the
board and again Rook D4 yeah
definitely irina's well-versed in her
classic Rook endings
uh
yesterday yes I mean that's what
Champions do they bounce back and boy
was that uh ever uh a tough one I I
spoke with Arena and asked her why she
didn't play the move Queen G6 and she
said well exactly at that point I was
thinking I was better and I wanted to
keep my queen centralized a few moves
thereafter she was looking to trade
queens and she ended up losing a pawn
while doing so
yeah sometimes we
push too hard exactly and then
unexpected happens you actually end up
losing I know
cold shower it's the most most
definitely
no just two moves away from covering
checks with the Rook exactly King C6
Almira wants to say something Almera no
Mira wants some help
yes I'm looking I'm going through the
database because I think that Bell is
going to be in our studio very soon so I
won't to understand if uh what has
happened in the opening yeah Queen B3
because this move has been actually
played
just until uh Bella joins us we'll just
hold off and watch the current ending
that's going on
uh Arena about to
receive a handshake I think
harika doesn't
she just doesn't want to resign no
because it does not feel good it doesn't
feel good no
no
but Irina today she got an advantage out
of the opening and just outplayed her
opponent all the way I really liked her
decision a bishop takes E4 uh
yeah earlier and now the simplest is
just with D5 same idea as before you
just want to build a bridge uh for your
king Rook to D5 so you can play Rook to
B5 and I'm sure she'll play it without
too much thought
she's just confirming
and I'll move D5
and there's Magic
wow uh a really really nice bounce back
by Arena
losing yesterday uh
to castanoke yeah and uh typical of her
tournament up and down yes she started
wonderfully when in two games she had
two and a half out of three and then
then came the Lost drawing another loss
I'm sure that was unexpected for her but
she recovered very quickly with the win
right and she has two more games to play
and
last round she's gonna play be playing
the tournament later yeah we were
talking about Anna's road ahead and what
Anna is facing and
uh Bella's road ahead I mean I I'm
feeling sorry for round eight and nine
her opponents uh for around eight and
nine I mean they're saying what the heck
is going on four in a row
the little boy stopped her for a moment
exactly it was Dubai
once again our standings after seven
rounds uh in the history books here we
go we have Anna satonski in the clear
lead with four and a half points
really closely following with four
points and Sharon third Elizabeth pets
and Irina Crush were three and a half
so it's interesting after Elizabeth lost
today she's still in the third place
exactly
and in the clear fifth we have Alexander
costing you with three points but just
to remind everyone some of these players
still have a free day coming up a buy
right where some of the other players
will have a chance to catch up with them
indeed and I wonder if we have in studio
not quite yet getting there as uh well
the bell of the ball will be joining us
very very shortly as she won nice game
it was out of the opening by the way
that Elizabeth
really got tricked and if you don't see
it right here this is where she
acquiesced Bishop E7
Knight takes E4 is very nice move Knight
takes E4 now if you think of D takes E4
and you see Knight G5 and Bishop C4
pretty scary I'm busted I I can't do
that I can't play Knight you have to see
Queen E7 which is a rather hidden move
at first I didn't see this idea at all
but anyway
yes but to ask and answer all of her
questions Amira's studio with Bella
uh yes Bella has just joined us in the
studio congratulations Bella once again
I wanted to tell you we love you you
don't have to win all these games you
can stay
I love it
so how does it feel like you want the
fourth game yeah I'm surprised myself
but it feels really good I'm delighted
that I could manage uh one four games in
a row
Bella was it the bluff
I thought that this was interesting
during the game so but you didn't
prepare this before you did no I I
wasn't prepared against this variation
so okay yes it was an interesting
variation but what if 90 foreignazzi
suggested this move uh take Knight takes
him home Queen is seven
yeah I was thinking something like this
let me just be shocked me too and Castle
I don't know if you should be too here
then our first Knight F6 95
through this possibility or not now F6
is coming yes there is a few F6 as well
so me I think maybe one of the moves
here was also Bishop G5 yeah that's
something something should be okay so
let's have a look at the game but here
you have a clear Advantage yeah here I
was thinking about 94
but I think after it takes F6 it should
be better anyway Knight of success so
she chose this plan to
transfer at least 926
there's a very interesting maneuvering
game yeah
so we didn't understand what was going
on so I wanted to play 93.95
somehow I did not
you didn't manage yes but did you
consider the long Castle also at some
point or not at all you were always yeah
Kathleen short here okay so just instead
of H5 I was thinking maybe C5
I don't know I probably have to take and
queen D1 or frequency five nights
after B6 94 probably yeah
just a very nice position but maybe you
can Castle because here after Bishop B6
yes I think you have a very comfortable
Advantage here so
Elizabeth tried to stabilize the things
here with H5 a nice thing interesting
plan I think
yeah
maybe Knight G5 was not the most precise
move maybe but I could not find any
better
so 95 and H4
and then here
to reach three yes there was
an interesting position
let's see here you played very well and
you took on C5 did you consider the move
negative 3 and Knight H4 here yeah I did
but after 96 Knight H4 I don't know I
thought that maybe
was possible in that night it takes a
four and
somehow I think that
taking on C5 was better
but decision here actually we thought
that there is a draw like after yes
because then instead of if you take on
C2 and check checks yes
how can you defend
because I want to bring my Rook
King V1 and probably
then yes and then the relation changes
completely after an ID for the computer
thinks that black is much better yes we
were thinking about King D2 but then
rugby8 and draw
I was thinking something like this but
that's just anyway that was a quite
complicated position in the time travel
and then I think that your opponent
missed G4 here yes
through King F3 she had a chance 92 no
yes that was a very very interesting
moment so yes what did you what just
don't look here what did you want to
make here I don't know I was thinking
about this position for a long time and
um
I could not find a really good mom this
the computer you know where does the
video suggest Rook H4 I think it's the
only movie yes but after rookie three
King Ito Rook E3 King D2 probably I
think here you have to play King F2 and
does it because there is a temple very
important taking on G4 and then King G6
I don't I don't know what what is this
nevertheless yes it's a very complicated
position and here you're already
completely winning so you just have to
be precise
yeah so let's have a winning position
here
so Bella you're still in the race for
the first place in this tournament two
games left yeah
okay
[Laughter]
well we're looking uh well it's seeing
to see you in the studio boy thank you I
think they're scared now you know when
you enter the plane hole you know they
run away
thank you Bella Bella oh congratulations
but a very quick question for you what
is your best winning streak
yes did you win four games in a row five
games in a row actually I don't remember
so this might as well be your best
winning streak probably yes in such a
strong tournament yes in such a strong
tournament probably wow very very good
luck indeed Bella you're thrilling as uh
with your victories and four in a row
amazing wow
her road ahead that starts to get very
very interesting suddenly too because we
know Anna's wrote ahead uh an arena
right and uh well that was only half
Point behind exactly exactly so much to
play for well as we wrap up yet again
another eventful broadcast is around
seven games uh we have to say that uh
the the number of decisive games keeps
impressing us because we we started
today with an overall score of 63 but
increased it but we increased it with
the 75 percent score of today as we have
another guest in studio getting uh all
set up with Amira with Irina
Irina congratulations thank you another
important win but we were mesmerized by
this move A4 I'm pretty sure that this
is your opening preparation how far did
you I guess uh
you know the computer
liked this move
um but in general yeah like why does the
main ideas in this position is for white
to play on the queen side and um you
know black and either play A5 here or
queen B4 and actually on Queen before I
kind of improvised because I mean I knew
there was this bishop E2 95 Knight D3
idea but I was like okay I kind of want
to start with King A1 because it's
useful
um pretty much in every position and
that way there's like none of this like
Knight C4 Knight A3 business right it
really discourages that
um so that was me basically like
disagreeing with the computer and you
know trying my own thing but eventually
I went to the you know um Bishop E2 plan
well sir king beard and we had the
feeling that uh everything went your way
in this game it was a very clean game so
your opponent failed to find any counter
play
yeah well of course during the game it
felt a lot more complicated like okay
the movie F5 really surprised me because
it looks very anti-positional you know
but a few moves later then I was kind of
questioning that I was like oh okay
she's improving this light Square Bishop
maybe I somehow messed up I mean I think
her main idea in F5 is if I go for
example G5 I think she's going for F4
yeah that's for example the nice point
of her move that she's going to be
improving the bishop if I take there's
Bishop F5
Bishop D3 and then uh you know take they
have to take with the rook and yeah at
least like rook hf8 and basically I have
a lot of weak pawns and uh so I didn't
want to go for that so it wasn't like so
simple for white to just take the dark
squares so I played 95.
um yeah she played Knight D7 Knight D3
here was like a really big thing for me
after Queen D6 because again I was
thinking should I go for G5 and allow
her to play H6 and basically for example
yeah H6 let's say I go H4
uh let's say it takes takes
on G5 Rook H1
uh and and then basically like let's say
queen E7 right so this okay I see the
computer wants me to just give away the
G5 Pawn that wasn't so obvious because
basically on F4 Bishop G8 you know she
has some play against E3 and I uh wasn't
so sure about this position and that's
why I had a really long think I went for
um
for A5 yeah and and then I kind of
realized okay she wants to take on G4
play H5 it seems reasonable
we can uh go there and she took with a
knight yeah I'll tell you what I think
was my best move of the game of what's
coming up we liked it yeah 984 like okay
that's pretty standard this so like she
went for this and then I think this Rook
age G1 was like kind of important
um yeah like because I have some choices
I can take on G6 but I think this move
yeah no I mean it's funny because at
this point I was like oh my conception
has worked out right like I hadn't been
so sure but at this point I was like
this is really quite nice and after 94
white just has like a huge choice of how
to play
um you know A6 B6 and I'll just tell you
the other big line that I thought about
after A6 B6
I was thinking about F3 here
um with the idea like Knight G3
um yeah because Knight F2 doesn't work
and then okay I didn't I was looking at
E4
and I thought this was really good I
mean she kind of has to take play Knight
H5 I'm probably gonna win a pawn so it's
kind of like a question of choosing yeah
between this position and here I was
even gonna go like Bishop C2 and then E5
you know and it was a question of like
choosing between this position and the
other one and it was quite difficult
choice because they're both they're both
good
but here you're yes
your opponent is completely deprived of
any Contour place so you converted I
would say work dg1 yeah my technique was
not so bad here because at first I was
just going to take the pawn but then I
realized like no I should not just make
automatic captures I think Yasser taught
me that one
am I done yeah I'm innocent we discussed
uh we discussed the fact that maybe I
should see some you know kind of
intermediate moves first and yeah B4
like that whole thing worked out quite
well so I mean it looks like yeah my
technique was it was all right here yes
and Irina
one question once again you know if you
wouldn't be a chess player yeah what job
would you choose yeah well I've always
enjoyed writing so that's one
possibility
um and when I was little I had this idea
that I could also be a lawyer you know
because in general I like uh arguing I
like digging for the truth
um you know analytical thinking and um
yeah I think uh I got that sort of pit
bull style you know that would work for
for law
thank you very much Irina and
congratulations once again thank you
absolutely our congratulations as well
Arena I mean bouncing back after a very
very tough loss that she did
hat tip just very very very well done uh
really really good game and uh kept the
pressure up uh from start to finish yes
and let's just take a look once again
after seven rounds of play here are our
standings we have Anna zatoski in the
clear first with four and a half points
closely following Bella hot tennis
Philly in the second place with four
points and Sharon third Elizabeth Pence
and Irina Crush exactly Alex
and when Anna comes back tomorrow our
pairings are as follows
Alexander Costner who will be playing
Bella Hotel Nashville
and our tournament leader Anna satonski
will be placing transai Abdul Malik and
by round for Elizabeth pets exactly
and Amira I've sum it all up for us your
final thoughts of this round seven of
the Karen's cup uh yes this was another
exciting round so we have three decisive
games today another 75 percent and well
while Anna was not here I wanted to
underline that she is about to make
history if she wins this tournament so
she's writing her own history she's so
close for to her first GM norm and while
I was looking at the chest well the
results and understanding so I wanted I
was thinking that how physical chess is
and what the what is the difference
between the players who had played a few
tournaments before and they they are
they played the Grand Prix and those who
didn't play and actually now the players
they do feel it
so the physical Dimension which we do
not describe very often actually is very
important it's a sport absolutely you
come with a lot of energy or you come
tired at being played in a very
important competition before yeah and
this tournament is very long so being in
good physical shape and having enough
strength to Finish Well is extremely
important absolutely well once again I
just want to say it was really a lot of
fun and I see uh been great calling the
action thank you so much for sharing
your day with us tell your friends where
you're hanging out and we'll see you all
tomorrow for round eight join us
tomorrow let's go
[Music]
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited